en matière de masques nous souhaitons
les premières livraisons évidemment
gratuite pour tous comment d'ailleurs
faire appliquer les gestes barrières et
la distanciation sociale dans le cadre
scolaire
l'italie a repoussé l'ouverture des
établissements scolaires à la rentrée de
septembre
comme d'ailleurs leurs commandes notre
propre conseil scientifique
c'était aussi notre avis aurons-nous
suffisamment de masques pour tous les
usagers où en sommes-nous en la matière
vous y avez répondu partiellement mais
rendez vous le 11 mai pour voir si les
actes sont en corrélation avec la parole
une réflexion qui peut s'étendre à la
question des tests
emmanuel macron ont déclaré souhaiter
rendre accessible le système de test
dans tous les pays du monde
lors d'une visioconférence avec les
membres de l' oms
nhem en france aux rays lui répondre
donner des leçons c'est bien se les
appliquer c'est encore mieux
à la date du 25 avril la france a testé
quatre cent soixante trois mille
personnes contre 2 millions en allemagne
un million six en italie nous n'arrivons
toujours pas à augmenter notre capacité
à tester pourtant le succès du
déconfinement en dépendent
l'om est ce le 16 mars a clairement dit
tester tester tester et massivement
nous demandons solennellement que toutes
les personnes travaillant ou vivant dans
des milieux confinés soient testés dans
toutes les entreprises les ehpad les
hôpitaux les écoles les prisons et
société transporte partout où cela est
nécessaire
confinement déconfinement huis clos
stop-and-go confinement masque inutile
puits obligatoire
écolo verte puis fermé restaurant fermé
jusqu'en juillet puis en juin ordre
contre ordre il est tout de même
difficile d'y voir clair dans votre
stratégie
nous devions aujourd'hui initialement
discuter uniquement de l'application de
traçage des malades appelé stop qu'ovide
et nous en parlerons si j'ai bien
compris mais nous ne connaissons rien
aux implications concrètes de cette
application ni même son utilité réelle
je pense qu'il faut s'éloigner de cette
mauvaise idée car le flou est total et
les dangers bien réels
vous n'agissez pas vous réagissez dans
un désordre tout mac rognant depuis le
déclenchement de cette épidémie que vous
avez sous-évalué
nous ne pouvons pas rester éternellement
confiné mais la confiance doit être
forte pour faire repartir le pays
correctement économiquement il faut
décider d'un choc de défiscalisation
pour les commerçants artisans libéraux
en aidant les collectivités a exonérés
des taxes locales et en compensant la
dgf partout où c'est possible je n'ai
pas le temps d'évoquer tous les sujets
que vous avez abordé mais je voudrais
vous parler des maires il paraît tout à
fait normal qu'ils soient partie
prenante dans ce plan mais il ne
faudrait pas qu'il soit utilisé comme un
nouveau par avant par le gouvernement
nous avons déposé avec mes collègues du
rassemblant nationale une proposition de
loi visant à les protéger en cas de
graves problèmes liés aux conséquences
de vos décisions
monsieur le ministre et je conclus si
nous notons un changement perceptible
dans votre stratégie et une certaine
prudence
nous voterons contre vos propositions
car nous considérons qu'il existe encore
trop de questions restées sans réponse
pour pouvoir se faire un avis éclairé
merci merci chers collègues avant de lui
donner la parole je suis heureux de
souhaiter la bienvenue à madame camille
gaillard minier devenue devenue le 17
mars en remplacement de monsieur olivier
ferrand député de la première
circonscription de l'isère
chers collègues vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues pour freiner la
propagation du court un ami russe commis
19 et assuré la bonne prise en charge de
nos concitoyens dans les hôpitaux
le président de la république a dû
recourir à une mesure inédite dans notre
histoire
demander aux français de rester à leur
domicile après 47 jours de confinement
l'horizon s'éclaircit l'avenir se
dessine et cela grâce à tous nos
concitoyens qui par leur discipline leur
engagement leur patience ont permis de
casser l'ascension de la courbe
épidémique l'esprit français cet esprit
de résilience qui a marqué notre
histoire aura une nouvelle fois été
démontrée
l'atteinte du plateau épidémique était
la condition sine qua none pour
envisager le déconfinement vous venez
monsieur premier ministre d'en dessiner
les grands principes
il faut tout d'abord vous remercier
d'avoir pris l'initiative de présenter
la stratégie de déconfinement de votre
gouvernement au sein de notre assemblée
c'est une marque de confiance vis-à-vis
les représentants la nation à travers
nous c'est au peuple français tout
entier que vous venez de parler depuis
le 17 mars
notre économie souffre en témoignent les
chiffres du chômage parues hier pour
mars 2020 certains secteurs n'ont pas eu
d'autre choix que de fermer et d'autre
de ralentir fortement leur activité dans
le même temps d'autres ont poursuivi
malgré la tempête de rendre leurs
services indispensables auprès des
français que soit de nouveau remercier
ici tous ceux qui ont tenu la barre
malgré les difficultés et parfois les
risques en premier lieu les soignants
mais aussi des accompagnants de
personnes âgées et des malades
les livreurs les caissières les rippeurs
et services publics de nettoiement de
transport le formidable tissu associatif
qui s'est mobilisée sans relâche ses
remerciements ne sont naturellement pas
exhaustifs nous députés de la majorité
veillerons à ce que des engagements pris
pour soutenir financièrement ses efforts
et revaloriser ces professions dont on a
vu le caractère essentiel ne soit pas
oubli
et après le déconfinement le plan de
déconfinement construit par votre
gouvernement est basé sur
selon l'expression vous avez choisi
monsieur le premier ministre une ligne
de crête un point d'équilibré à trouver
entre la nécessité de relancer
l'activité et pour préserver l'emploi
d'une part et la prise en compte des
enjeux sanitaires d'autre part vous avez
exposé plusieurs mesures 2 et
confinement qui permettront un retour à
l'emploi progressif et la garantie d'une
relance économique de notre pays tout en
assurant la sécurité sanitaire de tous
nos concitoyens commerçants artisans
professions libérales employés salariés
usagers et consommateurs avec le
déconfinement c'est une partie des 350
1000 points de vente au détail que
contre la france qu'ils vont pouvoir
rouvrir et retrouver ainsi une activité
et un chiffre d'affaires à l'exception
comme vous l'avait annoncé des grands
centres commerciaux depuis les quarante
mille mètres carrés qui resteront fermés
il est essentiel que la réouverture des
magasins sap en panne un arsenal de
moyens mis à disposition des commerçants
et de leurs employés pour leur mise en
sécurité ainsi que celle de leurs
clients
toutefois cette épidémie ne doit pas
faire oublier les difficultés
structurelles auxquelles ce secteur fait
face
je pense notamment aux grandes
plateformes de e-commerce qui impose
souvent une concurrence à laquelle ce
secteur ne peut pas répondre
cette période de confinement en plus de
son impact massif sur l'économie de
notre pays a montré l'importance du lien
social et du lien intergénérationnel
or bien souvent ce sont les commerces de
proximité qui ont joué ce rôle entre les
habitants notamment dans les zones
rurales et périurbaines
ce constat appelle nécessairement une
réflexion plus profonde
quant à l'avenir de nos commerces de
proximité et à leur protection face à
une concurrence est déséquilibré nous
déconfinement prévue le 11 mai prochain
ne concernera pas toutes les parties
prenantes de ce pan de notre économie
je pense aux acteurs du tourisme et de
la restauration plusieurs dispositifs de
soutien économique actuellement en
vigueur seront maintenus et des
annulations des charges sont d'ores et
déjà prévus pour garantir leur pérennité
vous avez annoncé monsieur premier
ministre qu'un calendrier de
déconfinement spécifique à ce secteur
qui emploie directement plus de 1,5
million de personnes sera exposée fin
mai ces professionnels prennent date il
est déterminant qu'il soit en mesure de
se projeter et de préparer leur reprise
les chefs d'entreprise leurs salariés
sont inquiets des entreprises si elles
n'ont pas été fermées ont été
contraintes de réduire voire de stopper
leur activité elles ont été aidés
soutenus par de nombreuses mesures dans
le seul objectif était de leur permettre
de maintenir la tête hors de l'eau
plus de 1 million d'entreprises ont fait
appel au fonds de solidarité 30
milliards d'euros ont été accordés avec
le prêt garanti par l'état plus de 10
millions de salariés eurent recours au
dispositif de chômage partiel ce qui
équivaut à un salarié sur deux ces
mesures inédites et structurante ont
permis à notre si notre tissu économique
de résister à cet arrêt de nombre
d'activités économiques et sociales
arrêt brutal mais nécessaire pour
freiner l'épidémie
ce n'est pas un feu vert que donne notre
gouvernement mais un feu orange
clignotant redémarrer oui mais de façon
progressive territoriale et sous
condition du respect des règles
sanitaires
demain les salariés devront pouvoir
retrouver le chemin de leur entreprise
mais à condition de leur garantir une
véritable protection permettant la
reprise de leur activité en toute
sécurité
pour cela il est nécessaire de mettre
tout le monde autour de la table car la
clé du déconfinement sera le dialogue
social pour chaque secteur économique il
s'avère indispensable qu'au sein de
chaque entreprise
les employeurs les salariés et les
représentants du personnel discuter
envisage ensemble les conditions du
déconfinement c'est le travail en commun
des partenaires sociaux avec le
ministère des solidarités de la santé et
celui du travail qui a permis de que
soit élaboré les guides de bonnes
pratiques
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
premier mis ce ne sont pas moins d'une
quarantaine des guides sectorielles
notamment le protocole de l'oppbtp tpf
une trentaine de guides transversaux qui
ont été rédigées depuis un mois c'est
absolument remarquable d'autres guides
de bonnes pratiques sont encore à écrire
dans les prochaines semaines afin que
l'ensemble des secteurs de l'économie en
soit muni avec le déconfinement si la
majorité des actifs vont continuer de
télétravail est une partie d'entre eux
va reprendre ses déplacements pour se
rendre sur son lieu de travail plus de
plusieurs grandes métropoles comme celle
de grenoble mais aussi montpellier lyon
ou rennes ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
vouloir accélérer le déploiement des
modes de transports alternatifs doux
s'inspirant d'initiative de l'urbanisme
tactique
la crise aura été de nouveau un
révélateur des possibles des
possibilités multiples qui s'offrent à
nous en matière de transport grâce à la
mobilisation des collectivités locales
mais de nombreuses personnes n'auront
pas d'autre choix que d'utiliser les
transports en commun un accroissement de
l'offre de transport est dès lors
indispensable pour leur permettre de se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail dans des
conditions sécurisées
l'augmentation de l'offre de transports
publics est ainsi naturellement partie
intégrante du plan de déconfinement
aujourd'hui 7 % des trains à grande
vitesse et 15 % des trains express
régionaux circulent sur le réseau 30%
pour les lignes de métro à la ratp à
partir du 11 mai la reprise progressive
à certain nombre d'activités ira de pair
avec la possibilité d'accéder à une
offre de transport plus large jusqu'à 50
% du niveau d'avant la crise l'afflux de
personnes supplémentaires sera couplé à
un renforcement des mesures sanitaires
déjà en vigueur dans les transports en
commun un possibilité d'acheter des
tickets dans les moyens de transport
sens de circulation dans les bus et le
métro par exemple se rajoutera j'ai
entendu notamment le port obligatoire du
masque et la réservation de certaines
heures à certaines populations
la coopération entre les autorités
transports et les établissements publics
comme privés dans chaque territoire sera
également nécessaire pour imaginer des
solutions d'horaires de travail
échelonné permettant de lisser les
heures de pointe les collectivités
territoriales auront également un rôle à
jouer afin d'adapter l'offre de
transport y compris scolaires en
fonction des besoins exprimés et de la
situation sanitaire observé avec la
volonté d'adopter des solutions au plus
près des territoires et des besoins des
usagers des plans de mobilité inter
entreprises seront aussi mobilisés par
le secteur économique et les
collectivités
c'est le cas par exemple dans la
métropole lyonnaise pour penser
différemment le trajet domicile travail
et avoir une offre de transport
complètes et sécurisées
la réussite de l'après mais reposera
enfin sur le couple préfet maire il leur
appartiendra de coordonner de façon
adaptée aux spécificités du territoire
les mesures que vous avez dénoncé la
situation de paris et de l'ile-de-france
ne peut se comparer à celle d'une région
très rurale chacun le comprendra
chaque territoire a ses spécificités ce
qui justifie une mise en pratique
différencier du déconfinement nous avons
besoin d'un état stratège qui
définissent le cadre général tout en
s'appuyant sur les acteurs de terrain
pour adapter les mesures et prendre
initiative qui conviennent c'est le sens
de la différenciation territoriale que
nous avons prenez tout au long du mandat
la remise en route
indispensable de notre économie devra
s'accompagner d'une nouvelle règle pour
corriger des insuffisances révélées par
la crise sanitaire
je pense naturellement à la
relocalisation industrielle des secteurs
stratégiques et à la consolidation de
filières d'excellence comme la filière
santé
il faudra se lancer dans l'élaboration
d'un plan de transformation de notre
société
compatible avec les objectifs
climatiques et environnementaux
notamment par la mise en avant des
mesures de soutien qui améliore l'impact
environnemental des industries et
services concernés au niveau national et
européen il faudra relancer une europe
qui doit peser davantage et jouer la
souveraineté économique environnemental
social et sanitaire pour que demain le
progrès que nous défendons soit synonyme
d'une société plus durable et plus
protectrice mais avant cela il nous
faudra ensemble réussir le déconfinement
une nouvelle date s'apprête à entrer
dans l'histoire de notre pays après
celle du 17 mars 2020 date du début du
confinement
c'est celle du 11 mai 2020 date de la
sortie de confinement pour qu'elle reste
unique
il convient de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour éviter à tout prix un rebond de
l'épidémie c'est le défi qui se présente
à notre pays nous auront chacun un rôle
à tenir une responsabilité collective
comme individuel à assumer cet ensemble
unique que nourriture
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci jurco l'oeil
la parole la parole est à monsieur
aurélien pradié
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre les masques
ont été annoncés chaque semaine ou
presque
c'est même masque on était attendu
chaque semaine ou presque
au delà des annonces c'est la réalité et
la réalité seuls qui intéresse les
français vous n'avez pas donné
aujourd'hui de garanties solides sur la
question des masques aux explications
sur ce sujet monsieur le premier
ministre ressembler davantage à des
excuses qu'en est il des respirateurs
ceux qui ont tant manqué à nos services
de réanimation ceux commandés par l'état
est manifestement inadaptées aux soins
hospitaliers pour le coc vide ce
nécessaire pour réarmer nos hôpitaux en
cas de seconde vague
êtes vous réellement prêt au delà des
mots dans les actes monsieur le premier
ministre nous devons testé massivement
les objectifs que vous venez d'annoncer
son minimaliste en termes de tests ils
ne permettront pas de généraliser le
dépistage de tous nos compatriotes
quelle que soit leur situation la
réalité sur ce sujet c'est que vous
renoncez à massivement tester les
français ces trois questions
les tests les respirateurs les masques
sont les questions les plus essentiels
de tout depuis des semaines votre seule
stratégie est celle de la pénurie
multiplier les détails sur un blanc de
déconfinement est nécessaire mais cela
n'efface pas les carences encore béantes
dans votre stratégie
depuis le début de cette crise
historique les républicains ont toujours
privilégié l'intérêt général aux
postures partisanes
nous avons participé à tous les débats
nous avons soutenu les mesures
économiques
lorsqu'elle allait dans le bon sens nous
avons fait confiance
parce qu'au coeur de la bataille il n'y
a pas de place pour la division
à la différence d'autres nous n'avons
été ni sectaire ni buté mais aujourd'hui
avons-nous confiance car en vous
présentant devant nous avec une simple
déclaration sans véritable débat avec un
vote expédié vous demandez à l'assemblée
nationale une confiance inconditionnelle
vous refusez que nous attendions que
nous car corrigions que nous améliorions
il faudrait être d'accord avec tout ou
bien se taire monsieur le premier
ministre si vous étiez une infirmière
qui s'est propagé plus
semaine durant avec des sacs poubelles
comme blues de fortune si vous étiez un
médecin libéral qui a attendu de longues
semaines des masques qui ne venaient pas
si vous étiez une aide soignante qui
aujourd'hui encore les attend
auriez-vous confiance à emmanuel macron
et en votre propre gouvernement
si vous étiez un parent d'élève inquiet
de voir la reprise précipitée de l'école
sans une totale garantie sanitaire voir
les ordres et les contres ordre
auriez-vous confiance si vous étiez un
maire qui se débat seul abandonné de
l'état pour tenter de protéger sa
population
auriez-vous confiance si vous étiez un
député siégeant sur ses bancs observant
que le parlement n'est désormais
considéré que comme un accessoire
politique
auriez-vous confiance monsieur le
premier ministre si vous étiez un
français parmi d'autres auriez-vous
confiance à emmanuel macron et en votre
propre gouvernement
je crains que vous connaissiez la
réponse c'est non non vous n'auriez pas
confiance et non nous n'avons pas
confiance car il est impossible d'avoir
confiance en un gouvernement qui nous le
savons désormais à cacher la vérité a
menti sur la réalité des stocks de
masques disponibles
il nous est impossible de faire
confiance un directeur général de la
santé qui déclare le 4 mars à la
télévision que les masques sont inutiles
et qui aujourd'hui les recommande grand
public il est impossible de faire
confiance à un comité scientifique qui
le vert avril demandent une reprise de
l'école en septembre
ekiza dans une note du 24 avril quatre
petits jours plus tard dit sa confiance
pour une rentrée en mai comment espérer
la confiance alors que vous et vos
ministres avaient nourri une telle
défiance
tout cela monsieur le premier ministre
je pourrais ne pas vous le dire je
pourrais effacer les critiques
nous pourrions vous flatter et pour les
plus faibles d'entre nous peut être même
vous courtisé nous pourrions nous taire
sauf qu'aujourd'hui notre responsabilité
est de vous dire les choses comme elles
sont comme les français dépensent nous
voulons le déconfinement parce que nous
voulons rebâtir la nation nous voulons
que la france redevienne fortes sur de
nouveaux fondements avec de nouvelles
espérances
nous voulons redonner aux français les
libertés qui leur sont fondamentales
et qui souvent même leur sont vitales
pour y parvenir vous avez besoin du
parlement et des français que nous
représentons vous ne réussirez pas sans
eux vous ne réussirez pas sans nous ne
vous habituer pas à une forme dégradée
de notre démocratie et vos déclarations
d'amour d'aujourd'hui à l'égard du
parlement ne sont pas à la hauteur de
vos actes changez vos habitudes dit
enfin les vérités accepté de nous
écouter certes cessé de vous chercher
des excuses
en tout genre sans cela et c'est la
situation d'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
possible d'envisager une véritable
confiance
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame cécile rilhac
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
voilà six semaines maintenant que notre
pays est confiné voilà six semaines que
nous ressentons tous de l' angoisse pour
nos proches et pour nous mêmes face à ce
virus redoutable invisible et
imprévisible certains ressentent la
fatigue et la lassitude le deuil et le
chagrin
permettez moi d'avoir une pensée
particulière ici pour toutes les
familles endeuillées
depuis le début de cette crise cette
période est plus difficile à vivre
lorsqu'on habite à plusieurs dans un
appartement exigu lorsqu'on ne dispose
pas chez soi des moyens de communication
nécessaires pour apprendre se distraire
ceux d'un échangé et nous nous aurons
tous dans cette période le sentiment
d'isolement que peuvent ressentir
bon nombre de nos aînés il est encore
plus difficile à vivre
lorsqu'il devient impossible de remplir
le réfrigérateur ou que les tensions au
sein de la famille aboutissent à des
violences scandant le quotidien et
pourtant grâce à nos efforts collectifs
les résultats sont là la solidarité le
respect du confinement l'acceptation des
règles ont permis à plusieurs régions
d'être épargné et les régions les plus
touchées voit le taux d'hospitalisation
enfin baisser
l'espoir renaît et c'est une première
bataille gagnée contre le virus depuis
six semaines
l'intelligence collective s'est mise au
service de la lutte contre ce virus
pour juguler cette épidémie rendre le
quotidien de chacun plus supportable et
penser à demain
chaque acteur a su mettre ses
compétences au service des autres en
restant dans son champ de responsabilité
mais en ayant fait tomber les cloisons
c'est en tout cas ce que j'ai pu
constater de la part de nos
administrations et de leurs responsables
dans mon département le val d'oise
préfet d'avesnes directrice de la rs
élus forces de l'ordre et de secours
acteurs de la société civile économique
et associatif alors que nous sommes
confinés contraint à un immobilisme de
fait nous n'avons jamais été aussi agile
et prompt à écouter et à travailler
ensemble
le 11 mai prochain comme l'a annoncé le
président de la république dans sa
dernière allocution sera donc le début
d'une nouvelle étape
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées vont pouvoir ouvrir 2
r prudente et progressive nos
oppositions s'était alors empressé de
créer de l'inquiétude
là où de la sérénité était nécessaire
plongeon enseignants élèves et parents
dans le doute et la crainte dans ce
contexte où l'impatience prévost
certains voudraient des décisions
immédiates
je peux le comprendre mais des confiné
c'est tout sauf se précipiter c'est
anticiper
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nos concitoyens
attendent des réponses et de l'action de
la transparence de la rigueur et de
l'humilité bien sûr face à une opération
d'une complexité inédite
nous devons être capables d'adapter et
de réajuster nos décisions en permanence
en fonction des résultats de la
recherche et d évolution de l'épidémie
comme de celle de nos technologies car
la priorité demeure et demeurera
toujours la santé des français
nous allons devoir apprendre peu à peu à
vivre avec ce virus
j'ai moi aussi monsieur le premier
ministre admirez dévouement de
l'ensemble des personnels enseignants
mais sans oublier les recteurs et
rectrice les directeurs et directeur
académique les corps d'inspection les
chefs d'établissements les directeurs et
les directrices d'école et les agents
territoriaux
je veux le remercier très
chaleureusement pour leur
professionnalisme leur ingéniosité leur
sens du service public dont ils font
preuve pour informer rassurer et surtout
maintenir le lien pédagogique mais aussi
le lien social avec leurs élèves avec
nos enfants nous assumons que l'école de
l'après 11 mai ne sera pas celle d'avant
le 17 mars
demain ne sera pas hier en prenant la
décision de rouvrir les écoles
nous avons une attitude responsable cas
cette décision fait partie d'une
stratégie avec mes collègues de la
majorité
je salue cette stratégie à l'
architecture claire et responsable qui
associe toutes les parties prenantes sur
le terrain c'est une confiance en
l'esprit de responsabilité de chacun
j'ai bien noté que cette ligne de crête
sera accompagné de précisions
indispensables pour la mise en oeuvre
pratique ultérieurement
ainsi vous annoncer la réouverture
progressive des écoles maternelles et
élémentaires à partir du 11 mai avec des
groupes maximum de 15 élèves sur la base
du volontariat
les collégiens suivront les 6e et 5e le
18 mai les lycéens professionnels fin
mai et vous attendez la fin de ce
premier stade dont vous nous avez parlé
pour capter une rentrée des lycéens et
des autres niveaux
concernant les masques que vous avez été
de claire obligation pour les personnels
de la petite enfance obligatoire pour
les enseignants lorsque la distanciation
social ne peut être respecté et
obligations pour les collégiens et
lycéens
car malgré la crise sanitaire
exceptionnelle à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
il est important que chaque élève puisse
poursuivre une scolarité dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
pour cela nous devons tout faire pour
limiter les inégalités sociales
territoriales ou numérique
à ce titre je voudrais saluer les
décisions du gouvernement notamment le
versement sans délai d'une aide
exceptionnelle aux familles avec enfants
les plus modestes afin de leur permettre
de faire face à leurs besoins essentiels
ainsi que le plan daide aux élèves les
plus démunis en termes d'équipements
informatiques et numériques
il faut que cet effort sont maintenus
par tous les élèves en ont besoin des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville à la
grande ruralité en passant par les
centres bourgs et les coeurs de ville le
numérique est devenu du jour au
lendemain
l'unique outil pédagogique à disposition
des enseignants et des élèves
et cet usage forcer à révéler ces
inégalités
notre école ne doit pas reproduire
encore moins accentué les inégalités
mais elle doit les combattre
notre système doit poursuivre son rôle
de service public
il est un maillon essentiel de notre vie
collective de notre société
demain les élèves rentreront à l'école
progressivement pas tous en même temps
en sachant que tous les enseignants ne
pourront pas non plus être présent tout
le temps tous en même temps les équipes
pédagogiques vont devoir s'adapter à
être à la fois dans les murs et hors les
murs à la fois en présentiel et en
distance yale ceci ne pourra se faire
que si les objectifs de cette reprise
sont claires pour chacun
pour rassurer parents enseignants et
élèves
ne faudrait-il pas affirmer que les
programmes ne pourront être tenus que
les évaluations et la prise en compte de
la civilité devra tenir compte de la
situation de chacun dans et hors les
cols que la priorité sera d'accompagner
chaque élève non pas dans l'acquisition
de nouveaux savoirs mais dont la
stabilisation de ceux de l'année le
déconfinement sera le succès ou l'échec
de tous
disait le président de notre assemblée
il ya quelques jours nous avons besoin
d'une stratégie nationale partagé de
règles communes et d'un rythme adapté
l'une des clés du succès sera la mise en
place d'un protocole sanitaire précis
opérationnel est stricte ce plan
national pour qu'ils soient déclinées
est adapté à tous les territoires doit
être accompagnée d'une méthode de
co-construction avec les élus locaux les
partenaires sociaux et tous les acteurs
de terrain c'est une autre des clés de
la réussite
aucune école ne sera ouverte si elle ne
respecte pas ce protocole sanitaires
strictes et ferme
il est essentiel que les personnels de
direction les enseignants les
associations de parents d'élèves soient
associés tout au long du processus de
réouverture des écoles et c'est ce que
fait le gouvernement
et c'est ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
depuis ce début de confinement associés
vis-à-vis des acteurs tous les acteurs
de l'éducation
vous avez décliné monsieur le premier
ministre les lieux possibles de cette
scolarisation salle de classe domicile
études dans des locaux dans l'école
voire des sites inhabituel que pourrait
être la cour le gymnase l'espace public
même par endroits afin de proposer des
activités autour des thèmes de la santé
du sport de la culture et du civisme
ainsi il faudra s'assurer que
l'organisation des établissements
scolaires permettent la formation de
l'éducation est un pardon scolaires
permettent à formation éducation des
élèves aux gestes barrières et à la
distanciation sociale et je sais pouvoir
compter sur l'implication des acteurs de
la médecine scolaire à ce sujet faire
confiance aux acteurs du terrain pour
adapter l'organisation du temps scolaire
à chaque établissement est très
important
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
vont pouvoir s'appuyer sur des
partenaires existants ou en créer de
nouveaux pour permettre à chaque enfant
à chaque jeune de prendre un rythme de
travail de renouer avec les
apprentissages de scolaires dans un
cadre commun travailler à leur
orientation
ceci est fondamental il sera alors
nécessaire monsieur le premier ministre
d'expliciter clairement leurs
responsabilités les responsabilités de
chacun et au besoin de les encadrer
réglementairement afin de rassurer
toutes les parties prenantes de cette
organisation inédite est nécessairement
la question budgétaire devra elle aussi
être précisé pour
klur je dirais à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
si nous voulons à la fois préserver
l'égalité des chances de nos élèves sur
l'ensemble du territoire
si nous voulons oeuvrer à un système
juste alors il est essentiel de bâtir
ensemble collectivement cette stratégie
de déconfinement le lundi 11 mai ne sera
possible que si nous continuons d'être
civique responsable solidaire
respectueux des règles communes et je
sais que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
sont à la tâche depuis le premier jour
pour garantir la continuité des services
publics notre sécurité notre santé notre
salubrité notre approvisionnement
s'occuper de nos malades de nos enfants
de nos aînés des plus démunis ne
comptant ni les risques ni les heures
aussi je tiens à leur adresser nos
remerciements et nos sincères et notre
sincère gratitude pour le travail qu'ils
fournissent
monsieur premier ministre enfin vous
nous avez proposé une stratégie reposant
sur la confiance sur les acteurs du
monde économique associatif social sur
le civisme des français alors en tant
que député je ne commenterai pas je
voterai pour la stratégie que nous avait
proposé
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame annie genevard
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames madame et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les députés sert collègues
parmi toutes les mesures que vous avez
annoncé il en est une qui concerne
particulièrement qui concentrent
particulièrement l'attention de nos
concitoyens il s'agit du déconfinement
scolaire parce qu'il touche toutes les
familles tous les âges tous les
territoires
parce que rien ne préoccupent davantage
les français que la santé de leurs
enfants
n'en doutons pas vos préconisations
seront examinés à la loupe la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation vous avez auditionné
monsieur le ministre l'éducation la
semaine dernière et vous nous avez
expliqué les grandes lignes du retour à
l'école rentrée pour tous sauf pour les
enfants en contact avec des personnes à
risque et je le nez sur trois semaines
par groupes de quinze élèves
quelques jours après le président de la
république annoncé le retour à l'école
sur la base du volontariat
nous avions aussi entendu parler d'une
rentrée pour les élèves en difficulté
seulement si l'on ajoute à cela la vie
du conseil scientifique préconisant la
rentrée en septembre
la confusion a atteint des sommets et le
résultat ne s'est pas fait attendre
les deux tiers des parents n'enverrait
pas au moins un de leurs enfants à
l'école c'est grave c'est grave parce
que plus de huit cent mille élèves ont
disparu des radars pédagogiques et ce
malgré le formidable engagement de la
plupart des enseignants la région en
revient à l'éloignement éducatif social
et culturel des technologies numériques
et de l'institution scolaire
c'est grave parce que le confinement a
fait exploser les signalements de
maltraitance familiale
c'est grave parce que beaucoup d'enfants
privés de repas scolaires ne mangent pas
à leur faim
c'est grave parce que les enfants à
besoins particuliers sont privés d'école
l'école qui répond à leur handicap et
soulage les familles voient les voilà le
propos d'une maman garder ses enfants
confinés à la maison est une épreuve
mais ce n'est rien à côté du maintien
d'un enfant souffrant d'un handicap à la
maison c'est grave parce que beaucoup de
familles sont épuisés par les tâches
supplémentaires que leur impose le
confinement scolaire à déconfinement
réussi impose la clarté et la cohérence
seul susceptible de créer le consensus
les parents et les enseignants
il est donc impératif de réussir cette
étape pour ces élèves en difficulté mais
aussi pour tous les élèves
tous les élèves parce que le confinement
les prive de la vie sociale qui
concourent à leur équilibre parce que
aucun écran ne remplacera et c'est
heureux la présence réelle et attentive
dame être auprès de ses élèves comme sur
nombre de sujets les députés les
républicains ont formulé des
propositions pour une reprise scolaire
obligatoire progressive en toute
sécurité
elles sont dictées par l'impératif de
sécurité sanitaire selon la méthode
allemande par exemple qui a fait ses
preuves
prise de température systématique test
chaque semaine pour le personnel
scolaire port du masque dans les
transports scolaires panier repas plutôt
que cantine il ne saurait pour les
républicains y avoir de retour à l'école
sans que ne soient garanties la santé
des élèves et des personnels
le compte y est il aujourd'hui avec les
propositions que nous avons découverte
aujourd'hui dans votre propos monsieur
le premier ministre nous avons des
doutes
si les parents les enseignants en
confiance ils laisseront leur enfant
revenir à l'école et eux-mêmes retourner
à leur vie professionnelle ce qui n'est
pas le moindre enjeu de cette rentrée si
particulière nos 50 propositions pour
adé confinement réussi poursuivre deux
objectifs essentiels concomitants est
totalement lié protéger les populations
et accélérer la reprise reprises dans
laquelle la question scolaire et
centrale vous voulez des propositions en
voici une
nous avons préconisé une mesure
d'avignon
la création d'une réserve enseignante
sur le modèle de la réserve sanitaire
mobilisables en cas d'épidémie par
exemple avec des missions que ne remplit
pas aujourd'hui la mission la réserve
citoyenne dédié souvent à des tâches
d'accompagnement est par ailleurs
largement méconnu les enseignants vont
être confrontés à une difficulté majeure
d'assurer des cours par demi classe à la
fois en présence physique est également
numérique comment cela sera-t-il
possible est supportable pour eux une
solide réserve enseignante y pourvoir
est puisque l'on nous dit qu'il va
falloir s'habituer à vivre un moment
avec ce virus avec d'autres peut-être
demain l'idée je crois mérite d'être
explorée la réouverture des écoles
relève de décisions de l'état mais les
maires doivent être complètement
associés et juridiquement sécurisé par
une charte
aujourd'hui c'est le flou le plus total
qui décide qui approvisionne angèle en
masque
comment doivent-ils s'organiser ils n'en
savent rien ne les laissez pas plus
avant dans la certitude d'autant que
vous avez besoin d'eux ils sont des
acteurs majeurs ne les exposez pas
donnez leur les moyens d'agir
efficacement
ils seront au rendez vous la politique
monsieur le premier ministre mais vous
le savez mieux que quiconque est un art
de l'exécution rien n'est plus vrai dans
cette si délicate opération du
déconfinement dont nous espérons comme
vous la réussite
il en va de l'intérêt des français et de
notre pays je vends merci merci jure
collègues
la parole est à monsieur daniel
fasquelle
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole chers collègues
bien monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président chers collègues je
voudrais vous parler quelques instants
du déconfinement économique
mais avant de le faire on a rendu
hommage à plusieurs reprises cet après
midi au progiciel de santé moi je
voudrais avant tout rendre hommage à
l'ensemble des postiers à chefs
d'entreprise salariés fonctionnaires qui
font tourner ses services essentiels et
qui tiennent le pays debout depuis le
début de la crise et je voudrais avoir
aussi une pensée pour bernard stalter
qui était un formidable président la
chambre des métiers d'artisanat qui
malheureusement est décédé de cette
terrible maladie
monsieur le premier ministre pendant le
décompte cependant le confinement l'état
a multiplié les mesures pour sauver des
entreprises ajustant régulièrement les
dispositifs regard des remarques du
terrain et aussi des remarques des
députés en partie des députés de
l'opposition
beaucoup d'argent a été dépensé on
pourrait donc penser que l'essentiel a
été fait que l'orage est passé que tout
va aller maintenant pour le mieux il
n'en est rien et on peut même affirmer
que le plus dur reste à faire car
inéluctablement nombre d'entreprises
vont voir leur rentabilité se dégrader
pendant le temps du 10 confinement
économique en raison de dépenses
supplémentaires d'un côté et d'un
chiffre d'affaires qui risque d'être
altérées de l'autre le défi est
maintenant devant nous il est simple
sauver toutes les entreprises qui était
viable avant le début de la crise liée
aux qu'ovide 19 et à ce sujet je
voudrais dire que j'étais quand même
aidé était partiellement déçu sur ce
point par votre discours puisque vous
avez à peine effleuré la question des
entreprises de la nécessité de relancer
l'économie dans notre pays et j'attends
de vous une attendons de vous monsieur
le premier ce que vous preniez ce sujet
à bras le corps parce qu'il faudrait pas
ajouter à la crise sanitaire
une crise économique et une crise
sociale alors pour éviter cette crise
économique et sociale il faut évidemment
tout d'abord faire du cas par cas parce
que d'un secteur économique à l'autre la
situation peut être tout à fait
différente et j'attire votre attention
sur notamment la question de l'avenir du
secteur du tourisme qui est aujourd'hui
en très grand danger thierry breton
notre commissaire appelé il ya quelques
jours à un plan marshall pour l'économie
touristique j'espère que et bien vous
serez lui emboîter le pas
à ce sujet et puis ensuite il nous faut
des mesures précises dans le cadre du
travail qui a été mené sous la houlette
de damien abad 50 propositions 17 de ces
cinquante propositions concernent le
déconfinement économique
ces provisions sont très précis j'aurais
simplement reprendre quelques unes cet
après midi je peux pas reprendre les 17
la première c'est de s'assurer que
l'ensemble des entreprises pourront être
équipés et pourront prendre reprendre
leur activité dans des conditions
normales sans mettre en danger ni les
clients ni les salariés ni la
responsabilité du chef d'entreprise est
ce que vous pouvez nous rassurer sur ce
point de ce que demain les entreprises
le 11 mai auront les moyens en masques
et en matériel pour pouvoir recommencer
convenablement leur travail sans mettre
en danger comme je le disais ni les
clients dit les salariés ni le chef
d'entreprise lui-même la deuxième
nécessité c'est de maintenir le chômage
partiel à ce sujet vous avez tout à fait
rassurés nous comptons sur vous pour
mettre en place que vous avez annoncé la
troisième proposition concerne les
charges sociales et fiscales
il faut absolument annuler les charges
sociales et fiscales
mettez vous à la place du commerçant de
l'artisan qui voit des charges fixes qui
n'ont pas diminué
pas de chiffre d'affaires et donc voilà
qui voit une montagne petit à petit
grandir devant lui qui pousse devant lui
et qu'il n'arrivera pas à gravir demain
si on ne veut pas voilà que des
entreprises bien ferme après avoir été
sommé dans le temps du confinement
pendant le temps du confinement
économique il nous faut absolument les
accompagner et comme le disait damien
abad avant moi il faut absolument annulé
ses charges sociales et fiscales
il faut aussi prendre en compte la
question des loyers et jeu de ce point
de vue le gouvernement fait fausse route
depuis le début faire pression sur les
grands bailleurs pour qu'il renonce à
revendiquer et demander le paiement des
loyers
ça n'est pas suffisant puisque en fait
vous avez quantité de bailleurs qui sont
parfois des commerçants qui ont pris
leur retraite qui ont besoin de ce loyer
pour complément de revenu pour
complément de retraite donc il faut le
dire une autre voie
ces deux voix c'est celle du fonds de
solidarité qui doit être plus fortement
abondé et qui doit absolument permettre
de prendre en compte une part
si des charges fixes notamment des
loyers je pense ici aux petits
commerçants aux artisans et aux
indépendants est ce que vous avez mis en
place de ce point de vue n'est pas
suffisant il faut un vrai accompagnement
pendant le temps du déconfinement
j'ajouterai que le prêt garanti par
l'état d'un an est insuffisant il
faudrait monsieur le premier ministre a
ajouté un an à ce qui a été prévu de
façon à ce que les entreprises et plus
et véhément recours à ce prêt garanti
par l'état 290 milles seulement prêt
pour 4,5 millions d'entreprises on voit
bien que ça ne fonctionne pas
suffisamment et que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont été re non sans avoir
recours à ce à ce prêt garanti par
l'état on pourrait ajouter la nécessité
aussi que l'ensemble des assureurs et la
même politique à l'égard des entreprises
c'est à dire une prise en charge d'un
minimum de leurs pertes d'exploitation
il faut aussi relancer les marchés
publics et vous n'avez pas parlé des
conseils municipaux pourquoi ne pas
installer rapidement les conseils
municipaux du moins de ceux qui sont
élus au premier tour pour que l'on
puisse relancer les marchés publics sur
tous ces sujets nous attendons monsieur
le premier ministre et sur d'autres
vous avez proposé tout à l'heure dans
votre discours d'enrichir votre plan et
bien voilà des propositions pour
enrichir votre plan merci nous écouter
merci continuer à vous mobiliser pour
les tailleurs établissements du pays
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur philippe gosselin qui sera le
dernier orateur
[Applaudissements]
voilà chers collègues
merci monsieur le président on nous vole
a donc réuni pour débattre du plan 2d
confus pardon de déconfinement prévu par
le gouvernement
dernier orateur beaucoup de choses ont
été dites c'est vrai mais avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet je voudrais
vous dire combien nous sommes ici
responsable responsable de ce que nous
allons voter de ce que nous disons et
nous ne doutons pas monsieur le premier
ministre qui ne soit pas la même chose
pour vous pour chacun des ministres
c'est évident au delà de nos différences
je ne pensais aussi particulière pour
nos collègues qui sont chez eux qui nous
écoute parce que d'une certaine façon
ils sont bien ici avec nous au milieu de
nous je le dis de cette façon et vous
avez raison de les applaudir
nous représentons aussi l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens ce n'est pas rien ou
représentant la nation là aussi dans sa
diversité dans sa singularité et nous
portons en ce moment cette charge
particulière émotionnel aussi parce que
tant de nos concitoyens sont touchés par
la maladie alors à elle à eux
nous pensons particulièrement et nous
avons une responsabilité oui vous avez
évoqué monsieur le premier ministre ici
devant la représentation nationale
votre possibilité finalement de ne pas
venir parce que la constitution ne vous
y oblige pas c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
vous l'avez fait et vous avez bien fait
ce n'est pas une aumône
car ici les députés en effet ne pas peut
pas il ne commande pas ils votent ils
décident ils essaient de contrôler et
d'évaluer l'action du gouvernement
et ça ne me paraît pas secondaire dans
un moment particulier où beaucoup
d'institutions pourrait vaciller la
nôtre ne vacille pas la république est
toujours debout et c'est heureux nous
sommes une part de cette république
il faut dire que jusqu'à présent le
parlement a plutôt été malmenés il faut
bien le reconnaître il ya eu de gros
efforts je regarde la présidente de la
commission des lois qui a fait beaucoup
d'auditions qui a su réunir si je puis
me permets de ses troupes comme d'autres
bien évidemment mais l'horizon pour un
retour à la normale est loin d'être
dégagé et même nos ordres du jour sont
complètement blackboulé sandell exemple
encore aujourd'hui presque ridicule
initialement le président de la
république
avait annoncé le 13 au soir un débat sur
le tracking et puis nous avions fini par
arracher un vote à la dernière minute
pratiquement sur ce débat la semaine
dernière et puis ce week-end on a changé
et nous sommes revenus à une discussion
globale sur le déconfinement et puis en
écoutant vos propos monsieur le premier
ministre nous apprenons que finalement
marche arrière
nous allons à nouveau nous trouver avec
un débat sur le tracking sur le
numérique et avec vote nous avons
évidemment beaucoup de chance et nous
l'apprécions mais vous comprendrez que
ces rebondissements multiples nuit quand
même à la crédibilité de la parole
publique et comment voulez vous c'est de
l'agilité ma ce niveau là ça devient de
la gymnastique qui peut faire mal aux
adducteurs
chers collègues et je ne voudrais pas
qu'il arrive à quelques difficultés à
monsieur le premier ministre surtout en
ce moment on a vraiment besoin de lui je
me pose la question de savoir si c'est
la dernière version est ce que l'on doit
vous croire je l'espère oui en tout cas
l'opinion publique et c'est ce qui est
fâcheux et bien perturbé par ce type de
gymnastique pour reprendre l'expression
de notre collègue la cdu sportifs de
haut niveau et je voudrais éviter dans
une situation aussi dramatique que celle
ci de faire de l'humour totalement
déplacé en réalité si nous sommes aussi
en difficulté sur ce sujet du trafic
et si nous insistons autant c'est qu'il
est révélateur de l'état de l'opinion
publique sur nos libertés individuelles
et publiques
ce n'est pas rien depuis le 23 mars
nous sommes dans un état d'urgence et je
le dis avec d'autant plus de
responsabilités que j'ai défendu cet
état d'urgence au nom du groupe l'est
républicain
au mois de mars en étant présent j'ai
voté nous avons voté cet état d'urgence
parce qu'il s'imposait mais il n'empêche
que depuis le 23 mars
nous sommes dans un état d'exception un
état exorbitant du droit commun et il
apparaît important de se préoccuper des
libertés individuelles et collectives
car on n'a pas simplement toucher un ou
deux éléments notre droit positif
ce sont des pans entiers qui ont été
bousculés de droit social de droit pénal
de droit de la sécurité sociale du droit
des collectivités locales etc et des
obligations
ce sont des grands principe à valeur
constitutionnelle qui ont été
chamboulées la liberté d'aller et
venir de circuler ce n'est quand même
pas rien et nous allons avoir deux mois
de pouvoir des sections d'exception
supplémentaire puisque une nouvelle loi
va proroger le tout nous dit on vous
nous l'avez appris tout à l'heure
jusqu'au 23 juillet alors comprenez que
le débat que nous voudrions que nous
aurons donc je l'espère sur le tracking
sur le flicage
selon certains sur les bracelets
électroniques généralisée selon certains
aussi est un débat important
je ne dis pas que le bracelet est
généralisé le bracelet électronique je
ne dis pas ça monsieur le premier
ministre
mais comprenez que ce débat sur les
libertés individuelles et collectives
soit un débat important qui préoccupe
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
vous avez bien compris que la cnil
n'était pas hostile par principe elle a
rendu la semaine dernière un avis qui
est en quelque sorte un cahier des
charges
la cnil n'ayant pas été saisi sur un
projet particulier à donner je conclu
monsieur le le président a donné
quelques préconisations importante
et puis il faudra insister aussi
monsieur le premier ministre notre
souveraineté numérique
il ne sert à rien d'avoir un serveur
national
si le traitement des données est fait à
l'extérieur c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec microsoft qui a signé
un contrat avec l'état
à propos de l'entrepôt des données donc
soyons vigilants et en conclusion je
dirais que si la peur est parfois
mauvaise conseillère
m conseillère elle nous amène à nous
interroger sur les fondements de notre
démocratie
et ça c'est plutôt heureux c'est ce qui
peut nous réunir car il n'y a rien de
pire la pagnol il reste les atteintes
aux grands principes des libertés ces
grandes libertés sont le socle de notre
démocratie
avec la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés je voudrais très
rapidement essayé de m'exprimer après
l'ensemble des orateurs en commençant
par les par les remercier pour leur
proposition quand ils ont formulé des
propositions pour leurs questions
lorsqu'ils ont posé des questions pour
les injonctions même qu'ils ont pu nous
adresser je le disais je pense que ce
débat est utile et je veux très
sincèrement les a remerciés avec
évidemment une pensée particulière pour
ceux qui s'inscrivent dans la logique
que j'ai décrite mai mais je veux
vraiment je le dis remercier chaque
orateur dans cette intervention
j'ai essayé de présenter les principes
de notre déconfinement j'ai bien
conscience que lorsqu'on décrit les
principes ou la stratégie globale on
peut se heurter et certains l'ont dit à
des questions sur la nécessaire
précision plus fine que l'on veut
apporter aux mesures qui vont être mises
en oeuvre
mais si je passe du temps sur les
principes sur les instruments que nous
utilisons c'est parce que je les dis
notre plan repose sur l'adhésion des
français et on ne peut pas adhérer à des
mesures pointu on doit pour adhérer aux
mesures qui seront mises en oeuvre
comprendre pouvoir comprendre vouloir
comprendre être en mesure de comprendre
ce que le gouvernement veut faire et
pour cela il faut l'exprimer le plus
clairement possible
la stratégie que j'ai évoqué ces
principes doivent être comprises de la
meilleure façon pour avoir une chance
d'être appliquée et pour avoir une
chance d'être efficace les principes la
conciliation entre l'impératif de santé
et la nécessité de continuité de la vie
de la nation
les instruments masque test isolement
la stratégie globale
beaucoup d'entre vous ont dit il reste
des questions mais vous avez tous
parfaitement raison et il en reste même
un nombre considérable et j'en suis
parfaitement conscient mais c'est
intrinsèquement même si j'ose dire qu'
il reste des questions car au fond le
plan national de déconfinement c'est une
stratégie nationale une architecture
générale celle que je viens d'essayer de
présenter et une addition de plans
locaux de déconfinement c'est en
fonction d'un cadre général qui est
proposé la possibilité commune par
commune département par département
d'appliquer de mettre en oeuvre de
corriger quand c'est nécessaire en tout
cas d'adapter quand c'est indispensable
ces principes pour qu'il puisse trouver
une application et trouver une
application adaptée au terrain j'ai
parfaitement conscience en disant cela
que j'entre dans une discussion
classique dans notre histoire politique
entre ceux qui pensent sincèrement qu'il
est préférable de donner quelques
principes pour permettre aux territoires
comme on dit parfois aux élus aux
organisations syndicales et patronales
aux entreprises de préciser localement
en fonction de leur capacité à le faire
de leurs spécificités locales
les meilleurs instruments et ceux qui
d'un autre comté pense que un plan
national doit prévoir des dispositions
qui s'appliquent partout de la même
façon
sous peine de faire courir le risque
soit de l'inefficacité soit du désordre
soit même parfois de la rupture
d'égalité et ce débat il est courant
dans l'histoire politique française je
suis certain d'ailleurs qu'il traversera
ça et là les discussions que nous aurons
à l'avenir
nous sommes sur une ligne de crête
franchement mesdames et messieurs les
députés je préférerais qu'on soit pas
sur une ligne de crête
ça fait longtemps que j'aimerais bien
avoir des bonnes décisions à prendre
en ce moment je choisis entre des
mauvaises décisions entre des décisions
qui sont moins mauvaises que les autres
nous sommes sur une ligne de crête et
est vraiment c'est une idée je sais que
vous au fond chacun l'aperçoit la
comprend nous devons éviter d'aller trop
loin d'un côté sinon c'est la
catastrophe
et nous devons éviter d'aller trop loin
de l'autre sinon c'est aussi la
catastrophe c'est véritablement une
ligne de crête et pour avancer sur une
ligne de crête
il faut de la prudence mais il faut
avancer je voudrais remercier les
orateurs qui ont formulé des
propositions certaines me paraissent
pouvoir être prises en compte pour
d'autres j'avoue plus de doute lorsque
le président mélenchon m'invite à la
planification la planification toute la
planification je ne dis pas que c'est
sans intérêt
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le modèle
telles que la majorité du pays du reste
souhaite le construire mais j'entends la
proposition
lorsque le président a bad m'invite à
faire confiance aux territoires
apprenez la différenciation je lui dis
que j'ai le sentiment d'avoir dit
exactement cela de faire confiance aux
territoires et de prôner la
différenciation et faire confiance aux
territoires et prenez la différenciation
c'est bien justement ne pas tout dire au
territoire s'est fixé le cadre et
ensuite effectivement laissé aux au
génie local si j'ose dire
enfin au génie des décideurs locaux la
capacité de trouver les bonnes solutions
qui ne seront probablement pas partout
les mêmes c'est vrai et c'est pas grave
l'important c'est que ça fonctionne bien
et que ce soit cohérent avec une
stratégie nationale
j'ai entendu monsieur le député
fasquelle faire des propositions dans le
domaine économique
j'observe que nous avons déjà évoqué un
certain nombre de mesures de soutien
mais il a l'honnêteté l'amabilité de
bien vouloir le reconnaître je le
remercie nous avons évoqué un certain
nombre de mesures qu'il n'a pas lui-même
évoqué je pense notamment au plan de
soutien en faveur des restaurants cafés
hôtels qui sont dans une situation qui
est évidemment parfaitement spécifique
puisqu'ils sont fermées je pense au café
au restaurant ils n'ont pu arriver pas
loin d'exercer leur activité il va donc
falloir évidemment les accompagner et
les accompagner durablement
parce que on voit bien que le présent et
pour eux extrêmement rude mais que
l'avenir
mesdames et messieurs les députés car il
faut dire les choses clairement
le présent est compliqué parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas fonctionner mais l'avenir
est compliqué parce qu'ils vont devoir
fonctionner autrement et nous savons
tous que dans tel ou tel établissement
la rentabilité du fonctionnement repose
sur une utilisation intensive de
l'espace il suffit d'aller dans
n'importe quel café parisien pour se
rendre compte et pas seulement à paris
dès lors que les mesures de
distanciation vont devoir prévaloir
pendant encore quelques temps ce sera
compliqué pour les restaurants ce sera
compliqué pour les cafés de trouver
l'équilibré économique dont il disposait
avant les mesures de fermeture
c'est pour cela qu'il va falloir les
accompagner le président de la
république l'a dit vous le savez
d'ailleurs il l'a indiqué au sortir
d'une réunion avec les représentants des
organisations syndicales du dôme du
secteur pardon et il a parlé du maintien
du fonds de solidarité au delà du mois
de mai de l'exonération de cotisations
sociales pour les tpe/pme de ces
secteurs
pendant la période de fermeture et sur
la nécessité d'un plan de relance qui
devra accompagner en particulier ces
secteurs vous avez raison vous avez vous
avez raison j'ai venir monsieur le
président je vous avez raison de
monsieur bré le monsieur le député
fasquelle peut-être un jour monsieur le
député fasquelle de de dire que le sujet
de de la crise économique qui est déjà
là et qui vient est un sujet majeur est
un sujet extrêmement préoccupant il me
préoccupe
il me préoccupe parce que si quelques
très grandes entreprises qui ne sont pas
par elle-même les plus fragiles parce
que elle fonctionnait bien au moment du
confinement venait à s'écrouler
l'effet de domino sur une myriade de
toutes petites entreprises industrielles
indispensable pas simplement à la
production de ces grandes entreprises
mais au maintien de la souveraineté de
la nation se verrait menacé beaucoup
d'entre vous on te remis en cause les
conditions dans lesquelles nous voulions
intervenir pour sauver air france
derrière le sauvetage des compagnies
aériennes il y à l'avenir des fabricants
d'avions derrière l'avenir des
fabricants d'avions est une partie
essentielle du tissu industriel de tout
le sud-ouest de tout le sud ouest
j'allais dire de de montpellier jusqu'à
nantes et parfois jusqu'au havre et
ayant bien conscience mesdames et
messieurs les députés que si ces
entreprises sont tellement remise en
cause qu'elle venait à être fragilisé au
point de devoir disparaître c'est tout
le tissu industriel français qui se
trouveraient compromis quand je parlais
dans mon propos du risque d'écroulement
c'est aussi de cela dont je veux parler
il faut donc prévoir les moyens
d'accompagner pendant la crise les
entreprises sauvegarder ce qui peut
l'être et ensuite relancé ce qui pourra
l'être et cette indispensable et c'est
vrai que je n'ai pas évoqué dans le
détail ces sujets car je n'ai pas évoqué
dans le détail tous les sujets je n'ai
pas évoqué dans le détail les plans de
reprise d'activité dans les
administrations qui ont été fortement
impactés par le confinement certains ont
évoqué le monde de la justice
c'est probablement dans le monde de la
justice que la reprise de l'activité
sera le plus délicate pour une raison
pour une raison que l'on peut d'ailleurs
parfaitement identifié que la garde des
sceaux pourrait encore mieux détailler
points d'abord que c'est une activité de
flux qui étaient déjà soumises à des
problèmes de stocks si j'ose dire
activités de flux qui doit être fait en
continu mais retards de production si
j'ose dire
dans beaucoup de domaines activités qui
avaient été perturbés dans les mois qui
ont précédé le confinement par un
mouvement de grève dont chacun à
l'esprit l'importance et les impacts
donc c'est vrai que dans certains
domaines la reprise de l'activité va
être compliqué mais j'ai demandé à
chacun des ministres de faire dans le
domaine dont ils ont la charge
le travail de préparation de la reprise
d'activité du des continents c'est bien
naturel et je suis certain monsieur le
député go cela que vous aurez l'occasion
de poser les questions à la garde des
sceaux et qu'elle y répondra je salue
évidemment l'importance de vos
préoccupations et l'opportunité de vos
préoccupations sur les questions
relatives aux libertés publiques
beaucoup d'entre vous ont évoqué cette
question de l'application numérique
certains pour s'en inquiéter d'autres
pour s'en réjouir
encore une fois le débat aura lieu je me
suis engagé
en ce moment il ya énormément de
questions théoriques qui sont
passionnantes mais il ya encore plus de
questions pratiques qui sont difficiles
et je vous propose de nous concentrer
sur les questions pratiques les
questions théoriques sont passionnantes
quand on saura que l'application
fonctionne ça deviendra une question
pratique et théorique on pourra se poser
la question mais se poser la question
avant que l'object avant que
l'instrument de fonctionne me semble non
pas inintéressant mais peut-être un peu
prématuré c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai exprimé ce que j'ai dit dans mon
propos et je suis personnellement
impatient d'en discuter
je suis personnellement impatient d'en
discuter parce que je trouve que c'est
un sacré sujet et que on a tout à fait
le droit de se poser des questions
délicates
un certain nombre de un certain nombre
de parlementaires ont posé des questions
sur la façon dont le déconfinement
allait se passer notamment dans le
milieu scolaire
j'ai bien conscience que c'est le sujet
qui inquiète probablement le plus nos
concitoyens un certain nombre de
réponses ont été apportées aujourd'hui
nous avons dit que nous allions entrer
dans une discussion importante avec les
associations d'élus avec les élus
localement que nous allions laisser la
possibilité aux directeurs d'école de
faire des propositions de dire comment
chez eux ils pensent que les choses
peuvent bien s'organiser en fonction des
configurations des locaux qui commande
souvent parfois en fonction de
l'implication des personnels
je crois qu'il faut véritablement faire
confiance aux enseignants et aux
directeurs d'école aux principaux de
collège lorsque les collèges pour les 6e
et la cinquième seront rentrés de façon
à ce que nous trouvions au cas par cas
les solutions les plus les plus adaptées
les plus opportunes et peut-être aussi
les mieux acceptées
en fait je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait
qu'une solution commandes et d'en haut
qui ne laisserait aucune marge de
manoeuvre locales pour s'adapter serait
in fine est toujours critiqué soit parce
qu'elle en fait trop
parce qu'elle n'offrait pas assez je
crois que là aussi il faut accepter de
faire confiance aux acteurs locaux
qu'ils soient élus ou fonctionnaires de
l'état et je me permets et je me permets
de dire je me permets de dire mais je
pense que cela mériterait un examen qui
est difficile en ce moment parce que
c'est difficile de comparer ce qui se
passe en france et ce qui se passe à
l'étranger mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'au
final en tout cas je veux bien en
prendre le pari qu au final leur
comparé à la façon dont la permanence la
continuité pédagogique a été garantie en
france par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
dans d'autres pays comparables
je ne suis pas sûr que nous rougir on
parce que je crois qu'en effet même si
elle n'est pas parfaite comment
peut-elle être même si elle n'est pas
totale puisque on sait qu'un certain
nombre d'enfants ont rompu ce lien ou
que le lien n'a pas pu être possible
avec un certain nombre d'enfants plus
tôt je pense qu in fine et nous pourrons
constater que cette continuité
pédagogique a été assuré plus tôt dans
de bonnes conditions et peut-être plutôt
mieux qu'ailleurs en tout état de cause
je veux saluer tous ceux qui s'en sont
rendus responsables et qu'ils se sont
beaucoup plus engagé on s'est beaucoup
certains députés ont sont revenus sur la
question de cette intervention du débat
qui la suit et du vote qui va la
conclure je voudrais rappeler que en
choisissant d'avoir recours aux
dispositions de l'article 53 de la
constitution
je ne me place pas en dehors du cadre
constitutionnel cet article qui est
d'ailleurs un bon article me semble-t-il
puisqu'il permet justement d'avoir un
débat général non pas sur un texte non
pas mais sur une déclaration donc sur un
sujet sur une prise de position
politique sur un engagement
ce texte permet exactement ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et je dis je
redis que le fait de permettre à chacun
non pas simplement d'émettre une opinion
et de voter de se positionner
individuellement sur ce sujet me paraît
opportun et donc j'entends les critiques
mais j'assume assez bien je crois la
méthode qui a été retenu est la
possibilité de voter qui est évidemment
offerte
enfin je voudrais noter pour jour / g je
voudrais noter
oui un point encore beaucoup de
questions ont été posées par le
président lagarde notamment elles sont
très bonnes
on va les prési sle précisée au fur et à
mesure certaines sont était déjà
peut-être exploser mais pas assez
clairement
mais dans le discours que j'ai prononcé
d'autres vont être précisées pas
simplement par le gouvernement mais par
la discussion avec les collectivités
locales je pense notamment à toute une
série de questions relatives à l'école
mais c'est vrai aussi s'agissant du
commerce
demain matin les questions au
gouvernement auront lieu ici à 11 heures
je crois monsieur le président elles
permettront aussi d'exercer cette
capacité pour chacun des ministres a
posé chacun des députés pardon à poser
des questions aux ministres et donc à
préciser la portée de ce qui doit l'être
enfin on m'a eu enfin je crois que c'est
tout monsieur le député je voudrais
l'installation des mères vous voyez je
réponds au débotté l'installation des
mères j'ai dit monsieur le président et
vous le savez parce que je les dis dans
des réunions vous étiez présent je crois
que j'étais favorable à l'installation
le plus rapidement possible des conseils
municipaux élus au premier tour parce
que c'est important pour le démocratie
parce que quand ils sont complets il
faut bien pouvoir les installer
parce que quand ils sont installés ils
peuvent commencer à prendre des
décisions légitimes et notamment des
décisions d'investissement qui sont
indispensables et notamment des
décisions de coordination avec l'état
qui vont devenir évidemment
indispensable donc j'y suis favorable
la loire que nous avons voté prévoit que
le 23 - on puisse dire si on peut
s'engager dans l'installation des
conseils
c'est la procédure qui a été définie
c'est la loi bien sûr que si monsieur le
bien sûr que si monsieur le président
jacob pardon parce que je ne veux pas
faire je vais pas faire de débat depuis
cet hémicycle pardon mais c'est
exactement ce que prévoit la loi
monsieur le président jacob elle prévoit
d'une part elle prévoit deux rapports
enfin un rapport qui permet de
déterminer si l'installation des
conseils municipaux élus au premier tour
est possible et si d'autres pas le vote
au second tour du second tour est
possible le 21 ou le 28 juin donc c'est
exactement ça que la loi prévoit et on
va pouvoir le faire je crois je l'espère
le plus rapidement possible le simple
fait que nous parlions de déconfinement
au mois de mai permettra je crois de
pouvoir installer je l'espère en tout
cas
les conseils élus dès le premier tour
donc de ce point de vue là monsieur le
président jacob je rejoins votre
préoccupation et ça me fait plaisir de
pouvoir le dire parce que c'est pas
toujours le cas
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
députés je voudrais
je voudrais terminer en un mot pour dire
que la partie que nous devons jouer tous
ensemble est redoutable
quelqu'un a dit que la politique était
parfois un art d'exécution le
déconfinement sera évidemment un art
d'exécution et la borne avec beaucoup de
modestie parce que la question est la
partie est compliqué mais je voudrais
dire que parce que je dis mes
inquiétudes
je les ai dit s'agissant des médicaments
même si aujourd'hui je suis moins
inquiet je les ai dit s'agissant d'un
certain nombre d'évolutions des
comportements même si au fond de moi je
pense que le civisme des français
permettra d'atteindre les objectifs que
nous nous sommes fixés par ce que je
suis capable de dire mes inquiétudes
je veux aussi dire ma confiance c'est
une partie difficile que nous avons à
jouer
c'est une partie risquée je les dis
c'est pour cela qu'il faut être prudent
mais nous ne réussirons à rien si nous
ne sommes pas confiant et la confiance
c'est pas l'inconscience c'est pas la
béatitude
c'est simplement le fait que nous
sachions que notre pays avant lui même
les ressources exceptionnelles pour
affronter cette partie difficile et je
voulais terminer en exprimant cette
confiance merci monsieur le premier
ministre je donnais maintenant la parole
à un orateur par groupe pour cinq
minutes pour l'explication de vote
monsieur françois vous prônez vous avez
la parole pour le groupe liberté
territoire merci monsieur le président
chaque jour nos compatriotes nous font
part de leurs appréhensions leurs
questionnements votre discours au seul
comme il suffira t-il à les rassurer
rassure at-il les parents qui hésitent à
confier leurs enfants à l'école ou le 11
mai rassir at-il les maires et des élus
chaud tout regard de l'avis du conseil
scientifique rassurera peut-il les
salariés qui se rendent au travail
malgré le manque de masques qui
s'apprête à prendre les transports en
commun la peur au ventre rassure at-il
les entreprises fermées en particulier
restaurants et les cafés
je ne le pense pas ne le pensons pas
d'autant que nos compatriotes ont vu des
décalage important entre ce qu'ils
entendaient et ceux qui constatait nous
avons écouté vous avez détaillé six axes
du déconfinement vous avez répondu à
certaines questions soulevées
mais tant d'autres demeures et vous
venez de le reconnaître sur les masques
sur les tests même s'il ya des mieux sur
les conditions de la reprise de
l'activité économique sur les conditions
d'ouverture des transports et je
pointais peut-être un angle mort la
situation des français les plus
précaires comme certaines associations
nous le font remonter et nous devons
sans délai nous prononcer sur un tel
plan
sans une étude plus poussée sans pouvoir
l'amender sans pouvoir proposer avec la
chance de pouvoir être entendue alors
même qu'il emporte des enjeux de santé
publique majeur alors même qu'il a des
répercussions économiques sociales ou en
matière de libertés publiques de premier
ordre
cette façon de procéder ne garantit pas
selon nous un fonctionnement
démocratique satisfaisant de nos
institutions
monsieur le premier ministre les députés
de mon groupe ont toujours été au
rendez-vous récemment nous avons voté
les lois d'urgence vous donnant par
ordonnance les coudées franches
nous avons ôté les deux budgets
rectificatifs en responsabilité mais
aujourd'hui nous nous souvenons de
nouveau sur rompre qu'est ce qui motive
est de tenir un tel débat si tôt vous
pouviez présenter votre plan aujourd'hui
entamé des concertations avec les
collectivités
ensuite même si les particuliers
d'organiser concertation après la
présentation du plan puis venir au
parlement et procédé un débat comme au
sénat ce débat aura lieu le 4 mai et
présenter le débat d'aujourd'hui comme
un cadeau fait au parlement nous paraît
un peu exagéré ce débat d'abord
d'ailleurs devait avoir lieu sur le
stock co vide
et puis nous apprenons aujourd'hui que
ça sera reporté à plus tard à un autre
débat nous pouvons comprendre certains
tâtonnements l'ampleur et le caractère
inédit de la crise actuelle sont tels
qu'il est impossible de tout prévoir
mais certain entêtement interroge
jusqu'à la conception qu'a cette
majorité de l'exercice du pouvoir sur
cette verticalité avec laquelle vous
n'êtes visiblement pas encore tout à
fait rompu à la lumière des éléments
coûts venez de nous présenter des
manques et des absences que j'évoquais
la grande majorité des membres de notre
groupe n'apportera pas son soutien votre
plan en votant contre ou en s'abstenant
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame mathilde de panneaux pour le
groupe de la france
insoumise
monsieur le premier ministre nous sommes
en guerre nous sommes en guerre nous
sommes en guerre nous sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre dans la bouche du
président cette phrase servait de
formule magique pour excuser tous vos
mensonges vos artifices beau scandale
depuis le début de la crise nous ne
sommes pas en guerre nous sommes en
pandémie une pandémie qui indique que la
bifurcation écologique et commençait
d'ailleurs votre rhétorique guerrière
trouve ses limites
vous nous présenter aujourd'hui un plan
de déconfinement pas une signature d'un
armistice avec le coronavirus le virus
est un phénomène biologique qui n'a que
faire de vos grandes paroles et de vos
métaphores guerrières
il nous donne à voir ce que d'autres
crises peut-être plus grave encore
pourront produire
vous n'avez pas eu un mot durant votre
discours sur la crise sociale terrible
qui touche tant de français par un mot
pour les familles qui ont plus peur de
mourir de faim que du coc vite 19
pas un mot sur l'explosion du chômage à
venir votre plan de déconfinement et
hasardeuse vous vous défausser de vos
responsabilités sur les parents les
enseignants les chefs d'entreprise les
élus locaux
pire vous parlez dans des confinement
qui reposera sur le civisme des français
c'est odieux assumer le rôle de
planification de l'état pour assurer la
sécurité sanitaire du peuple français
et si nous étions véritablement en
guerre quelle pitoyable chef de guerre
vous seriez qui laisse les soignants
soi-disant au front sans munitions avec
des sacs poubelles en guise de sur blues
qui a livré des masques moisi en
outre-mer qui a laissé les entreprises
exposées leurs salariés conduisant
notamment décès d'achat caissière à
carrefour des suites du coc vite 19 qui
laisse une partie de sa population dans
l' angoisse de ne pas manger à sa faim
oui vous êtes en guerre mais sûrement
pas contre le court aux navires us si
nous étions en guerre vous auriez
nationaliser luxfer seul producteur de
bouteilles d'oxygène médicale en europe
aujourd'hui fermée par la voracité des
actionnaires ou famars qui fabrique 12
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur vous auriez réquisitionner les
entreprises pour produire les tests et
les masques dans tout le monde sait
maintenant que non madame ndiaye
ils ne sont pas inutiles ils nous font
juste défaut si tel avait été le cas
vous auriez fait comme en 1916 où le
parlement a voté pour une taxe contre
les profiteurs de guerre
il s'agissait de faire payer les
entreprises qui avaient profité du
malheur national
ils sont nombreux à se gaver
actuellement ils ont des noms
amazon avec son pdg jeff bezos ce qui a
empoché 24 milliards d'euros depuis le
début de la crise au gf entreprise de
pompes funèbres profiteurs de mort qui
empochait 55 euros par famille qui se
recueillaient auprès du corps d'un
proche
il y en a beaucoup d'autres pendant ce
temps les aides soignantes finissent le
mois avec en moyenne 1300 57 euros nets
et 1150 euros pour les caissières
quand elles sont un temps plein si nous
étions en guerre vous auriez fait comme
en août 1914 en suspendant les loyers à
l'époque le parlement estimé
inacceptable que des familles de
combattants puissent être expulsé quand
les autres risqué leur vie pour le pays
non la seule guerre que vous menez c'est
celle contre l'intérêt général
le code du travail reste votre
adversaire compulsif vous avait abrogé
des rtt jours de repos des salariés vous
vous attaquez aux 35 heures est au repos
dominical
alors même que le nombre de chômeurs
sera tel qu'il faut réduire le temps de
travail pour travailler tous vous
sanctionnez l'inspecteur anthony smith
pour avoir fait juste son travail de
défense des droits des travailleurs vont
renflouer les caisses à coups de
milliards des entreprises polluantes 7
milliards ar france quand on compte 39
millions seulement de rhodes aide
alimentaire pour nos concitoyens vous
refusez de rétablir l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune
vous refusez de plafonner les prix des
masques en tissu pour ne pas freiner
l'innovation alors que l'urgence est à
freiner l'épidémie vous refusé
d'interdire le versement de dividendes à
la place vous envoyer le ministre de
l'économie tout penaud le béret à la
main demandez timidement aux entreprises
de ne pas le faire pour un brillant
résultat 4 7 milliards aux actionnaires
d'alliance 3,9 milliards pour ceux de la
bnp 1,8 milliard pour ceux de total 353
millions pour ceux de michelin alors que
vingt mille salariés bénéficient du
chômage partiel
pris en charge par l'argent public il
privatise les bénéfices vous socialiser
les pertes des milliards pour eux des
miettes pour nous nous pensions que vous
auriez compris les dégâts de vos
politiques qu'il fallait arrêter de
détruire l'hôpital public de casser nos
biens communs de détruire les
écosystèmes de laisser le privé régir
nos vies et nous priver de tout mais
vous ne changerez jamais
même dans ce moment de choc terrible
cette crise n'est pas une parenthèse le
montre les failles que vous avez créé
dans notre organisation de vie
collective alors revenir à la normale
revenir à ce qui à la cause même de
l'ampleur de la crise revenir à un pays
avec 9 8 millions de pauvres et un
record de millionnaires à en europe
un président qui méprisent celles et
ceux qui aujourd'hui à sur nos vies
dignes les soignants les caissières de
les éboueurs les routiers tous ces gens
qui hier il y appelait les rien nous
voyons déjà venir votre plan de relance
qui fait pression sur nos écosystèmes
nous voyons déjà sur vit surgir votre
monde d'après semblable à celui d'avant
encore plus prédateur plus destructeur
nous voulons un monde de paix de
solidarité qui respecte notre dignité
nous voterons contre votre plan de
déconfinement vous n'avez pas confiné
notre colère pour nous c'est plus jamais
ça plus jamais vous merci madame
panneaux la parole et à monsieur fabien
roussel pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ce premier ministre la
franchise et en mer de fraternité
permettez-moi d'être franc nous ne
voterons pas votre plan car il laisse
trop de place aux approximations et face
à un tel virus
c'est dangereux de plus il renvoie aux
régions aux élus aux élus locaux
d'associations chefs d'entreprise aux
enseignants aux organisateurs des
transports le soin d'organiser le
déconfinement alors qu'une deuxième
vague arrive vous n'annoncez aucun
moyens humains et financiers
supplémentaires pour mettre en place
cette stratégie pour l'éducation
nationale pour le dépistage pour rendre
gratuit un maximum de masques pour tous
les citoyens
vous renvoyez même aux français le soin
de les faire eux mêmes il y aura le
masque lvmh haute couture que portera
bernard arnault et puis il y aura celui
fait dans les quartiers avec beaucoup
d'amour et quelques bouts de tissus vous
annoncez même la réussite que la
réussite de cette stratégie reposera sur
le civisme des français mais les
français sont si vie qui sont
responsables ils sont majeurs mais que
dira-t-on du rôle et de la
responsabilité de l'état
comme beaucoup ici nous regrettons la
précipitation le manque de moyens qui
vous conduit à proposer un plan un
parfait incomplet et malheureusement qui
s'aiment toujours le doute
nous ne partageons pas votre manière de
vous décharger sur les maires sur les
entreprises pour mettre en place ce plan
vous invitez vous incitez vous
encourager alors qu'il faudrait édicter
des règles organise et contrôle et
écouter les élus écouté les partenaires
sociaux nous avons le même souci de
faire avec eux mais ce n'est pas leur
renvoyer la responsabilité de mettre en
oeuvre votre plan et vos décisions
la progressivité du déconfinement dans
le temps dans le pays tout cela nous le
partageons comme vous mais cela ne
s'improvise pas vous avez dû tenir
compte de la colère des gens de leurs
craintes sur l'école et nous nous
félicitons que les lycées ne rouvre pas
tout de suite
nous ne partageons pas en revanche votre
choix d'ouvrir les écoles le 11 mai et
sur la base du volontariat et sans
moyens supplémentaires
ceux qui t'ont sites qui sont en chômage
partiel avec un salaire partiel n'auront
pas le choix
ni ceux qui perdent leur emploi et qui
sont prêts à tout pour le retrouver ils
remettront leurs enfants à l'école et
celles et ceux qui ne veulent pas mettre
leurs enfants à l'école pourront-ils le
garder chez eux sans risquer une
sanction ou un licenciement
que croyez-vous que prévoyez-vous là
dessus nous vous demandons de mettre en
place toutes les conditions de sécurité
sanitaire avec les moyens humains en
face avant de décider d'une date
d'ouverture des écoles dans toute la
france et pour tout le monde
la république doit garantir les mêmes
droits pour tous dans toutes les
campagnes dans toutes les villes ici et
en outre-mer et pour tous les citoyens
c'est l'égalité de tous même face à un
virus nous demandons un minimum de
masques gratuits et aux normes pour
chaque citoyen nous voulons des prix
encadrés
vous ne pouvez pas continuer d'un côté
de protéger les plus riches et renvoyer
les français les plus fragiles les plus
démunis dans les pharmacies pour
s'acheter un masque face à un virus
mortel
nous voulons un pilotage de l'état sur
toutes ces questions celle de la
production du matériel celle du pilotage
des tests comme pour celle des brigades
de dépistage que nous souhaitons
également mais à la différence de vous
elle ne peuvent pas dépendre du bon
vouloir des mères ou des associations
locales pour avoir du personnel pour les
mettre en oeuvre
ça c'est du bricolage de même comment
laisser aux entreprises le soin
d'organiser le travail sans donner plus
de droits aux salariés aux syndicats les
conditions de travail les déplacements
les horaires tout doit être revu pour
faire face aux risques épidémiques
l'objectif de la reprise du travail
aujourd'hui ne doit plus être la
rentabilité mais plutôt de s'adapter aux
risques épidémiques et être l'occasion
de repenser complètement notre modèle
économique
tout le monde est prêt à retravailler et
à trouver des solutions tout le monde
aspire à ce que les enfants retrouvent
le chemin de l'école et au plus vite
mais pas à n'importe quel prix
pas pour faire comme avant nous voulons
donner un sens nouveau au travail à
l'effort collectif à la production de
richesses nous voulons que le
déconfinement soit synonyme de sécurité
de confiance mais aussi d'espoir
l'espoir de bâtir un nouveau modèle
économique protégeant chaque être humain
du virus préservant nos ressources
naturelles
en tissant notre souveraineté et les
valeurs de notre république si
fragilisés
au cours de ces dernières années c'est
dans cet esprit que nous avons formulé
des propositions en tenant compte de la
réalité de notre pays
ici comme dans les outre-mer où les
inquiétudes sont encore plus fortes
pour toutes ces raisons les députés
communistes et ultra marins du groupe
gdr voteront contre ce plan hormis un ou
deux qui s'abstiennent ou votent rond
pour merci merci monsieur roussel la
parole est à monsieur stanislas guérini
pour le groupe la république en marche
je je vous rappelle que s'agissant des
explications de vote
vous pouvez les exprimer comme l'a fait
monsieur people du débat ou de la
tribune comme vous le souhaitez voilà
non je l'indiquais parce que je suis
interrogé vous avez donc la parole chers
collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez prononcé
aujourd'hui en quelque sorte un discours
de politique générale de déconfinement
en le faisant
devant l'assemblée nationale vous ne
faites pas que démontrer votre
attachement à notre démocratie et à ses
institutions en soumettant le débat que
nous venons d'avoir un vote
vous nous demandez en quelque sorte
notre confiance pour mettre en oeuvre
désormais cette stratégie de
déconfinement et faire en sorte qu'elle
devienne partout sur le territoire
une réalité le groupe la république en
marche votre à en faveur de la stratégie
que vous avez présenté aujourd'hui et
donnera sa confiance
d'abord parce que cette confiance vous
ne l'avez pas demandé que pour vous et
votre gouvernement vous l'avez demandé
bien sûr pour que le gouvernement puisse
conduire le plan de déconfinement en
l'éclairant d'une doctrine commune
protéger tester isolé mais vous l'avez
demandé aussi cette confiance pour
toutes celles et ceux qui participeront
à la co construction et à la mise en
oeuvre territoire par territoire de ce
plan déconfinement l'épidémie que nous
vivons
l affaire de tous le plan ne
déconfinement que nous devons mettre en
oeuvre
l affaire de chacun et chacun doit
prendre sa part
ce sera notre succès commun où notre
échec collectif et vous avez fait le
choix des responsabilités partagées
nous approuvons l'approchent
territorialisée pour mettre en oeuvre ce
plan car c'est une affaire d'efficacité
le coronavirus n'a rien changé à la
diversité de la france nos territoires
n'ont pas été touchés par tous de la
même façon ce qui est nécessaire à
mulhouse ne l'est pas forcément à
bayonne ou ailleurs c'est pourquoi si
nous avons besoin de stratégies
nationales
ces modalités devront être déclinés en
fonction de la réalité locale
nous allons désormais à partir de cette
doctrine que vous nous avez présenté
écouter discuter avec les maires les
élus locaux
ceux qui ont la charge du quotidien la
connaissance la plus fine leur commune
et co construire avec eux qui font
preuve de tant de responsabilités
c'est un choix juste aproprié le groupe
la république en marche vous donnera sa
confiance car ce n'est pas une confiance
aveugle que vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui quand on prend une décision
aussi lourde que celle du déconfinement
avec sa part de risque rallumer le pays
après l'avoir mis en veille on ne le
fait pas sans conditions et vous avez
vous même apporté des conditions en
conditionnant le début du confinement un
examen la situation sanitaire le 7 mai
en publiant dès jeudi
tous les jours la carte de la situation
sanitaire par département vous ne nous
demandez pas de faire un choix aveugle
mais au contraire d'accorder une
confiance éclairé éclairée car
s'appuyant sur des données factuelles
sanitaire scientifique éclairée car
plaçant la santé des français
l'impératif de protection de nos
concitoyens au dessus des autres
c'est un choix cohérent et raisonnable
enfin nous vous accorderont notre
confiance car la mise en oeuvre du
déconfinement est une nécessité
elle ne l'est pas tant pour des raisons
économiques même si chacun voit à quel
point la situation est grave elle l'est
pour des raisons sociales pour des
raisons humaines et pour des raisons
sanitaires y compris le confinement
généralisée du pays
était un impératif grâce à lui grâce au
sens du devoir de celles et ceux qui
étaient en première ligne
l'hôpital a tenu l'hôpital tient le
confinement à sauver des vies
il nous a protégés collectivement du
risque sanitaire mais le confinement
parfois mais aussi en danger tout le
monde n'est pas à l'abri dans sa maison
je pense aux victimes de violences
intrafamiliales je pense aux plus
démunis aux mal logés à celles et ceux
qui ne peuvent plus approvisionner
malgré tous les efforts des réseaux de
solidarité dont les acteurs se démène
depuis le début de la crise
je pense aux victimes qui attendent une
décision de justice je pense aux enfants
qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir un
ordinateur pour pouvoir continuer à
étudier chez eux
c'est pourquoi le déconfinement est une
nécessité d'abord pour les plus
vulnérables
et c'est en pensant à eux et c'est en
veillant par la suite à ce que chacun de
nos concitoyens ne soit laissé sur le
bord de la route que nous voterons en
faveur de la stratégie de déconfinement
il ne s'agit pas d'héroïsme dans tout
cela il s'agit d'honnêteté
ces mots que camus a fait prononcer au
docteur rioux dans la peste résonne
tristement il faut le dire avec
l'actualité
l'honnêteté c'est ce que nous devons aux
français en tant que représentant du
peuple
l'honnêteté c'est ce qui caractérise la
stratégie de déconfinement que vous nous
avez présenté aujourd'hui
alors ayons l'humilité de notre
ignorance l'assurance de notre
résilience le courage de nos choix pour
aller ensemble vers des jours meilleurs
je vous remercie merci monsieur guérini
la parole comme monsieur jean carles
grelier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre dans cette crise les
français auront tous connus ils auront
connu le chant et les larmes
ils auront connu la mort qui rôde et les
affres de la maladie
ils auront connu le chagrin et la
tristesse mais ils auront aussi connu le
dévouement sans limite des
professionnels de santé dont
l'engagement est un sujet de fierté
nationale
ils auront vu à l'oeuvre des milliers
d'élus locaux partout sur les
territoires se démener sans compter pour
assurer au plus près des français
leur mission républicaine ils auront pu
admirer l'ingéniosité l'inventivité de
nombreux entrepreneurs ou de nombreux
bénévoles mettant leurs moyens
industriels ou artisanaux à la
disposition de tous pour fabriquer des
masques pour soutenir venir en aide
durant cette période la france aura tout
connu de la solidarité qui s'est
exprimée par des chants repris et
partagée d'un balcon à l'autre par des
messages d'encouragement sur les réseaux
sociaux et par des applaudissements tous
les soirs à 20h
les français auront donc tout subi des
privations du confinement une atteinte
forte à la liberté d'aller et venir un
isolement aux incidents ce psy chic
parfois très lourdes et ils ont fait
face avec responsabilité
conscient que dans un épisode épidémique
de cette ampleur chacun porte au fond de
lui dans ces comportements dans ses
paroles et dans ses agissements
un peu de la guérison de chacun les
français auront sans doute le moment
venu des comptes a demandé à un état qui
n'a pas toujours été au rendez vous sur
les masques sur les tests sur la
psychiatrie éternels oubliés des
politiques de santé mais
aujourd'hui l'heure n'est pas à rendre
des comptes l'heure est à sortir de
cette période avec au moins trois
impératifs or le premier de ces
impératifs c'est d'assurer le
déconfinement de tous les français en
garantissant le maximum de sécurité
sanitaire rien ne serait pire en effet
que de prendre le risque d'un effet
rebond d'une seconde vague que notre
système de santé ne serait pas en
capacité de gérer il faut donc plus de
masques et plus de tests beaucoup plus
de masques et beaucoup plus de tests
le deuxième impératif est de permettre à
nos hôpitaux et à nos cliniques de se
remettre à niveau en offrant d'abord à
temps de répit aux établissements et
surtout un temps de repos aux
professionnels de santé et pour cela
nous aurions aimé que votre projet
prévoit de confier à chaque chef
d'établissement la liberté et les moyens
d'organiser avec ses équipes avec ses
soignants les conditions de leur propre
sortie de crise le troisième impératif
c'est évidemment de relancer une
économie qui tourne depuis plusieurs
semaines au ralenti et dont les effets
commencent à se faire sentir avec dureté
pour nos entrepreneurs nos commerçants
nos artisans nos indépendances et tous
les français pour lesquels le chômage
partiel aura souvent apporté une
garantie mais aura aussi parfois
entraîner une importante perte de
revenus pour cela nous aurions aimé
entendre de votre gouvernement
l'annulation totale des charges pour
tous les commerçants tous les artisans
et tous les deux des indépendants sans
exception nous aurions aimé entendre
qu'un plan au moins aussi ambitieux que
celui de nos voisins allemands allaient
accompagner durablement l'investissement
et la compétitivité de nos entreprises
nous aurions aimé entendre qu'un
moratoire serait imposé tant à l'état
qu'aux collectivités locales sur toute
hausse d'impôts et pour une période d'au
moins non entendre enfin qu'un
abonnement spécifique du fonds de
solidarité logement pourrait venir en
aide aux familles en difficulté
pour tout cela monsieur le premier
ministre il aurait fallu que vous
preniez le temps de nous entendre et
mieux encore peut-être celui de nous
écouter il aurait fallu que vous nous
donniez le temps d'un débat qui dépasse
les quelques minutes les quelques heures
de cette après-midi alors nous aurions
pu ensemble définir des axes tracés des
lignes directrices offrir un projet
partagé à la france un projet pour les
acteurs de santé un projet pour les
entrepreneurs
un projet pour chacune et chacun de nos
compatriotes peut-être peut-être est-ce
comme cela que se construit une union
nationale pour le temps d'après
s'agissant d'un débat manqué comme l'on
dit d'une occasion qu'elle ait manqué le
groupe des républicains s'abstiendra
dans sa grande majorité non qu'ils
s'opposent au principe de votre
déconfinement mais il ne peut vous
accorder sa confiance ni son soutien sur
la foi de quelques engagements par trop
généraux qui aurait mérité un examen
parlementaire plus approfondie et donc
plus démocratique
je vous remercie si leurs collègues la
parole est à madame isabelle florennes
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues nous voilà arrivés
au terme de nos débats pour aujourd'hui
et ces débats ne cesseront pas ces
débats auxquels nous sommes toutes et
tous très attachés et nous sommes ici
certes en format restreint pour le faire
vivre encore longtemps
nous avions émis le souhait avec mes
collègues du groupe modem que la
stratégie de déconfinement soit sérieuse
prudente et progressive
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
avez rassuré et avait rassuré les
français
la stratégie que vous ne vous avais
présenté est prudente mais elle donne
des perspectives pour l'avenir sont
phasage dans le temps permet notamment
aux acteurs économiques d'organiser la
reprise de leurs activités
elle permet de retrouver une liberté
nécessaire comme vous l'avez dit mais
surveillez les élus locaux les préfets
excusez moi nous souhaitons également
ardemment que cette stratégie soit
adaptée aux spécificités de chaque
territoire et qu'elles puissent être
décliné en fonction des spécificités
locales
sur ce point on suit vous nous avez
entendu et nous vous en remercions les
élus locaux les préfets les
parlementaires doivent être au coeur de
l'adaptation et de la mise en oeuvre de
cette sortie progressive du confinement
car ce sont eux qui connaissent leur
territoire leur entreprise leur école ce
sont eux aussi qui savent ce qui pourra
se faire ou pas et dans quelles
conditions vous leur faites confiance
nous leur faisons confiance
et en cela nous avons raison il faudra
certes que des précisions soient
apportées en particulier pour la reprise
des transports en commun je pense
notamment à la région parisienne et à la
réouverture des établissements scolaires
mais nous comptons sur ce travail
collectif et locales pour trouver les
réponses adéquates
vous avez enfin défini le bon équilibre
entre l'urgence sanitaire et
l'indispensable reprise d'activité
il nous appartient maintenant à nous
parlementaires d'accompagner sa mise en
oeuvre
en étant présent auprès des habitants de
nos communes et de nos départements et
aller coûte plus que jamais des
personnes les plus fragiles vous l'avez
compris monsieur le premier ministre
vous pouvez compter sur les députés du
groupe modem et apparentés que nous
représentons aujourd'hui et auquel nous
pensons très fort pour être des acteurs
pleinement engagé dans la réussite de
son déconfinement et nous voterons donc
la stratégie que vous venez de nous
présenter
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame marietta
karamanli
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur et
madame la ministre vous venez de le
ministre premier ministre venait de
présenter donc les mesures que le
gouvernement va prendre pour assurer le
développement de nos concitoyens vos
propositions en oeuvre on ici l'objet
donc que d'un vote indicatif et il nous
faut réagir dans l'immédiat sans avoir
le temps d'un deux jours qui aurait
suffit de discuter du bien fondé de la
faisabilité des mesures annoncées
c'est vous le savez regrettable car
c'est une politique de confiance envers
la démocratie est ici vis-à-vis du
parlement dans votre notre pays a besoin
pour retrouver le 10 nations dynamisme
et son optimisme
nous nous sommes là donc pour pas pour
le discuter unis pour améliorer nos
coûts drôme atrium ont tout au long de
ces huit semaines
dans leur très grande majorité appliqué
avec sérieux avec solidarité avec
responsabilité
les prescriptions qu'il aurait été
imposée ce ne sont pas les principes du
dcau fondement qui pose aujourd'hui
question ce sont les modalités
techniques et pratiques qui soucie nos
compatriotes
si les mesures décidées ne sont pas
facilement applicables faisable si elles
ne sont pas suffisamment claire et
pédagogique
elle pourrait ne pas être bien appliqué
la préoccupation donc des députés
socialistes et apparentés et que de
retour le retour progressif à la normale
dans quelques semaines ou dans quelques
mois selon les sujets ne se fasse pas au
détriment de la santé ne se fasse pas au
détriment de l'intérêt de nos
compatriotes
les parents ne savent pas si mais si m
de leurs enfants à l'école sera sans
risque pour lui
pour eux pour les enseignants comment
interpréter le caractère facultatif du
retour à l'école et beaucoup d'autres
questions
les salariés et les demandeurs d'emploi
ne savent pas s'ils pourront accéder aux
transports pour le travail sans que cela
ne devienne
un combat quotidien harassant le
compatriote ne savent pas qu bien et
pour certains comment ils vont ils
devront payer pour les masques qui soit
utile est obligatoire pas un mot sous la
situation aussi dans les régions
d'outremer et c'était important ici
attendus tout au long de ces semaines
les français se sont mobilisés pour
trouver des solutions pratiques
pratiques aux problèmes rencontrés et
ils ont compenser les fragilités d'un
système d'état
tiraillé entre des consignes parfois
contradictoires et l'insuffisance de
moyens en faisant appel à la créativité
et à la solidarité
ils sont instruits de ce qui s'est passé
et aurait aimé quant aux comme ils le
disent parfois ils nous disent ce qu'il
faut proposer et faire la proposition
d'une application de pistage de
personnes malades au porteur sain sur
les mobiles de bon nombre d'experts nous
disent qu'elles ne sera pas efficace et
qui pourrait donc discriminer interroge
fortement
enfin une large politique de dépistage
qui aurait un véritable sens au début de
l'épidémie fesf est l'objet aujourd'hui
d'une interrogation en tout cas forte en
sortie de confinement vous l'avez
compris monsieur le premier ministre ne
montre pas un blanc seing à des mesures
qui en l'état sont peu praticable ou
dont nous connaissons pas le mode
d'emploi
si nous partageons la finalité nous
sommes opposés à la méthode qui a été
utilisé notre pays a besoin d'un
gouvernement non pas d'unité nationale
mais de démocratie pratiques et sociale
de support à des mesures claires est
égale pour toutes et tous aucun député
donc du groupe socialiste et apparentés
n'accordera sa confiance et votera à
l'immense majorité contre leurs
collègues
le dernier orateur et le président jean
christophe lagarde pour le groupe dit
agir et indépendance de la parole chers
collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre sur collègues au delà
des drames et des contraintes que les
français vivent depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines une d un des aspects
les plus terribles de l'épidémie qui
s'abat sur le monde sait qu'au fond
chacune et chacun d'entre nous est amené
dans chacun des gestes qu'il fait de sa
vie quotidienne à être face à sa propre
mort nous savons tous en réalité que le
quitteront un jour cette terre mais
toucher ce micro devient dangereux comme
l'exercice obligé je remercie le
président de nettoyage systématique nous
le montre à chaque pas de sa propre vie
chaque français sera pendant encore
plusieurs mois
obligé de se demander et de s'appliquer
à lui-même des règles comment est ce que
je fais pour me protéger et protéger mes
proches
si je commence par là une explication de
vote ça peut vous paraître bizarre mais
c'est qu'en réalité c'est ce qui est en
train de vivre à la fois notre peu près
l'ensemble des êtres humains sur cette
terre et ce n'est non seulement pas rien
dans les changements d'attitude entre
nous mais c'est énorme dans la volonté
et la capacité d'un peuple à retrouver
non pas la vie normale d'avant mais une
vie supportable est acceptable et c'est
monsieur le premier ministre d'une
certaine façon la difficulté du discours
que vous aviez a prononcé aujourd'hui
sortir de cet état de peur pour ne pas
dire de trouille accepté en réalité
notre condition d'être humain
notre fragilité mais aussi ce que vous
exprimiez entre le choix de
l'effondrement ou celui du coup
déconfinement accepter un risque et
c'est la mesure de ce risque
la condition de ce risque qui fera ou
non le succès de ce que vous n'êtes
présenter mais de ce qui doit se
construire dans les semaines à venir
entre les chefs d'entreprise et leurs
salariés
les maires et les écoles les élèves et
les parents parce que quand ils
reviennent de l'école il faudra aussi
faire attention
bref la difficulté principale je les ai
évoqué tout à l'heure aux fans à la fin
l'intervention c'est la confiance avant
nous confiance en vous avant nous
confiance entre nous je ne parle pas des
collègues ici mais des collègues dans
les entreprises des français dans les
transports de l'attitude et du civisme
que vous appelez de vos voeux et qui est
évidemment nécessaire et dont je veux
dire que j'ai été impressionné
à quel point les français finalement on
en fait plus preuve nous qui sommes
disons le un peuple plus tôt parfois
indisciplinés
nous avons été capables de discipline y
compris monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur vous le savez dans des
départements comme le mien la seine
saint denis si souvent stigmatisés mais
maintenant il faut redémarrer redémarrer
progressivement des parts et
intelligemment redémarré prudemment mais
redémarrer et c'est finalement ce que
vous avez essayé de dessiner ici j'ai
exprimé tout à l'heure que nous n'étions
pas d'accord surtout que nous avions
besoin sans doute de ce que vous appelez
territorialisation bien plus fort que
les élus locaux devaient avoir bien plus
la main ils rendront des compte pas les
préfets sauf devant les cinglés qui
multiplient les procès devant les
tribunaux et nous avons besoin en
réalité de construire ensemble encore
vous auriez pu le faire avant ce débat
vous commencez à partir de ce débat
j'aurais préféré que ce fut avant de
construire ensemble
cette confiance qui nous est nécessaire
je le répète pour à la fois survivre
économiquement et survivre sanitairement
dans la crise que vous avez eues à gérer
et très franchement monsieur le premier
je vais vous le dire les yeux dans les
yeux elle est difficile peu de gens ici
aimerait être à votre place et je vous
ai trouvé à la fois solide et sincère y
compris dans vos doutes et des
incertitudes
l'applaudissent et pas trop vite
[Applaudissements]
n'applaudissez pas trop vite
si je devais voter la confiance sans
doute plus à vous que votre supérieur
que j'ai trouvé moins solide et moins
sincères vous avez géré la crise
économique avec je crois beaucoup de
réalisme
la crise sanitaire avec un certain
nombre d'incertitudes et parfois de
difficultés il appartient maintenant à
la fois au gouvernement et à l'ensemble
des acteurs locaux de décider comment ce
déconfinement peut et doit être un
succès c'est une question je le répète
de confiance dans notre groupe
les voix comme je crois chez tous les
français se partageront se partageront
entre ceux qui accordent la confiance a
priori et c'est eux qui demandent que la
construisent ensemble je fais partie
monsieur le premier ministre
de ceux qui continuent à demander que
nous la construisons ensemble et je
pense que vous en aurez besoin non pas
de la mienne non pas de la nôtre mais de
celle de l'ensemble des français c'est
le chantier que vous venez d'ouvrir
construire la confiance ensemble merci
monsieur le président je vais donc
mettre aux voix
la déclaration du gouvernement relatives
à la stratégie nationale du plan de
déconfinement dans le cadre de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de kobe tu dix neuf je
vous rappelle écoutez bien que les
représentants des groupes sont porteurs
des voix des membres de leur groupe et
que les positions différentes communiqué
préalablement seront évidemment prise en
compte dans l'analyse du scrutin
j'invite donc les représentants des
groupes à voter qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient compte
tenu des positions de vote qui ont été
transmises au service de la séance
voici le résultat du scrutin nombre de
votants 571 nombre de suffrages exprimés
468 majorité absolue 235 pour l'adoption
3,168 contre sens l'assemblée nationale
a approuvé la déclaration du
gouvernement relatives à la stratégie
nationale du plan de déconfinement dans
le cadre de la lutte contre l'épidémie
de que vides 19 prochaine séance demain
à 11 heures
oh
[Musique]
avant nous
en vous
avant nous confiance entre nous je ne
parle pas des collègues ici mais des
collègues dans les entreprises des
français dans les transports de
l'attitude et du civisme que vous
appelez de vos voeux et qui est
évidemment nécessaire et dont je veux
dire que j'ai été impressionné
l'ordre du jour appelle la déclaration
du gouvernement relatives à la stratégie
nationale du plan de déconfinement dans
le cadre de la lutte contre l'épidémie
de covin 19 suivies d'un débat et d'un
vote en application de l'article 53 de
la constitution
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
la science est ouverte la séance de ce
jour est ouverte ouverte aux espoirs que
nous partageons avec nos compatriotes et
résolument tournée vers des lendemains
heureux que chacun d'entre nous appelle
de ses voeux
mes chers collègues l'heure n'est pas en
ces instants aux considérations
secondaires temps nous sentons au plus
profond de nous-mêmes avec le peuple
français que nous traversons une épreuve
qui marquera l'histoire de notre pays
l'histoire de l'europe et du monde avec
son cortège de peur et d'incertitude et
de doute en ces lieux empreints de
l'histoire féconde et tourmentée de
notre démocratie
nous savons tous combien nos valeurs de
liberté d'égalité de fraternité ont pu
être plusieurs fois mise à rude épreuve
cet hémicycle où la nation est
représenté avec eu des guerres des
drames des pandémies des catastrophes
naturelles
autant de moments saisissant qui
obscurcissent l'horizon
parfois cette noirceur color de
nombreuses existence face à la menace
sur noise de virus silencieux qui a déjà
arraché à la vie tant de femmes et
d'hommes de père et de mère deux frères
et deux soeurs d'amis et de camarades le
doute et la peur vient ébranler nos
propre rationalité tandis que
l'optimisme consubstantielle à la vie
conduit à s'accrocher à chaque espérance
naissante dans ce moment où l'impatience
et la traduction du désir de vivre
il nous faut admettre une part
d'ignorance et de tâtonnements il nous
faut reconnaître que les plaies de cette
crise s'annonce profonde et qu'il ne
suffira pas de mots pour les pensées
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
vous savez que vous ne gouverner pas un
phénomène qui nous domine et nous savons
mes chers collègues que la pandémie est
plus forte que n'importe laquelle de nos
lois nul impuissance à dire cela
seulement la conscience d'être rappelé
au tragique de toute histoire
individuelle ou collective qui rend
dérisoires toute vanité puisse mes chers
collègues cet ébranlement général nous
apprendre aborder les sujets dans toutes
leurs profondes complexité et non dans
leur apparente simplicité cette
responsabilité nous la devons aux
français puisque nous sommes la
représentation nationale
mes chers collègues vous n'êtes pas
seulement 75 députés dans cet hémicycle
effectifs exceptionnellement réduit pour
respecter les recommandations sanitaires
et je salue bien sûr tous nos collègues
dont l'absence physique ne doit pas
masquer le travail actif et la présence
à distance vous n'êtes pas seulement 75
députés
vous représentez la république dans sa
riche diversité avec ses sensibilités et
ses conceptions politiques différentes
vous n'êtes pas seulement 75 députés
vous portez l'attenté d'espérance de
millions de français qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui car l'histoire qu'ils nous
convoquent et seul de la vie quotidienne
de chacun et de notre destin collectif
cette responsabilité nous la devons
aussi à tous ceux dont l'énergie le
courage force notre admiration
les soignants les forces de sécurité de
secours les fonctionnaires les paysans
les ouvriers les salariés les parents
les élus de tous les territoires aussi
qui nous rappellent chaque jour que la
france est diverse et que de généreuses
initiatives solidaires fond de la
fraternité un ciment national face à la
tempête et donne corps à ce mot de notre
devise nationale
monsieur le premier ministre vous
témoigner à l'assemblée nationale en
profond respect en ayant choisi de vous
exprimer d'abord depuis cette tribune
vous recevrez l' écoute attentive d'une
assemblée habité certes par l'esprit de
concorde qu'impose le contexte national
mais bien sûr aussi dans le différend
ski
fondent notre démocratie même nul doute
que le riche débat qui va s'engager le
vote qui le clôturera permettra à chacun
de s'exprimer et de s'engager devant les
françaises et les français
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés voilà donc le
moment où nous devons dire à la france
comment notre vie va reprendre depuis le
17 mars dernier notre pays vit confiné
qui aurait imaginé il ya seulement trois
mois la place que ce mot à les prendre
dans notre débat public qui aurait pu
envisager une france dans laquelle
subitement les écoles les universités
les cafés les restaurants
une majorité d'entreprises les
bibliothèques les librairies les églises
les temples les synagogues les mosquées
les jardins publics et les plages les
théâtres les stades
tous ces lieux communs pour utiliser une
formule qu'affectionne le président de
l'assemblée nationale aurait été fermé
jamais dans l'histoire de notre pays
nous n'avons connu cette situation ni
pendant les guerres ni pendant
l'occupation ni pendant les précédentes
épidémies
jamais jamais le pays n'avait été
confinés comme il l'est aujourd'hui
et de toute évidence il ne peut l'être
durablement car si le confinement a
constitué une étape nécessaire
il pourrait si elle durait trop
longtemps entraîné des effets délétères
le confinement était un instrument
efficace pour lutter contre le virus
pour contenir la progression de
l'épidémie
pour éviter la saturation de nos
capacités hospitalières et ce faisant
pour protéger les français les plus
fragiles depuis le 14 avril dernier le
nombre de cas de kevin 19 hospitalisés
diminue de plus de trente deux mille
patients hospitalisés les descendue à
environ 28 milles depuis le 8 avril le
nombre de cas de kobe de 19 en
réanimation diminue il dépassait 7100
il est désormais de 4600 la décrue est
engagé elle est régulière lente
j'y reviendrai mais régulière selon une
étude de l'école des hautes études de
santé publique
le confinement aura permis d'éviter au
moins soixante deux mille décès sur un
mois et 105 mille lits de réanimation
aurait manqué en l'absence de
confinement je ne crois pas mesdames et
messieurs les députés que notre pays il
aurait supporté mais un instrument ne
vaut que si ces effets positifs ne sont
pas dans la durée
dépassé par ses conséquences négatives
or nous savons par l'intuition ou par
l'expérience qu'un confinement prolonger
au delà du strict nécessaire aurait pour
la nation des conséquences gravissimes
nous sentons que l'arrêt prolongé de la
production de pans entiers de notre
économie que la perturbation durable de
la scolarisation d'un grand nombre
d'enfants et d'adolescents que
l'interruption des investissements
publics ou privés que la fermeture
prolongée des frontières que l'extrême
limitation de la liberté d'aller et
venir de se réunir de rentrer visite à
ses proches à ses parents présenterait
pour le pays
non pas seulement l'inconvénient pénible
du confinement
mais en vérité celui bien plus terrible
du risque de l'écroulement écroulement
je n'emploie pas ce terme au hasard
mesdames et messieurs les députés
on me reproche bien plus souvent la
litote que l'exagération
il nous faut donc progressivement
prudemment mais aussi résolument pro
cd1d confinement aussi attendu que
risquée et redoutait
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
présenter à l'assemblée nationale et
grâce à elle aux français notre
stratégie nationale c'est à dire les
buts que nous recherchons et la façon
dont nous allons procéder pour les
atteindre
à compter du 11 mai prochain toute
stratégie repose sur des constats le
premier d'entre eux et médicales il
tient en quelques mots simples que tous
les français doivent avoir en tête
nous allons devoir vivre avec le virus
dès lors qu aucun vaccin n'est
disponible à court terme qu aucun
traitement n'a à ce jour démontré son
efficacité et que nous sommes loin
d'avoir atteint la fameuse immunité de
groupe
le virus va continuer à circuler parmi
nous ce n'est pas réjouissant mais c'est
un fait on peut espérer que le virus
disparaisse de lui même
les spécialistes des épidémies en tout
cas certains s'accordent pour
reconnaître que cela arrive que les
épidémies s'arrête parfois sans qu'on
sache très bien pourquoi on peut espérer
que l'incroyable efforts de recherche
engagés dans le monde entier permettra
de trouver sous peu un traitement et
d'ici 12 à 24 mois
un vaccin qui renverrait ce virus au
rang des questions de santé résolu par
l'intelligence et la technologie humaine
on peut tout à fait espérer tout cela
mais fonder une politique publique est
organisée la vie des français autour d'
hypothèse aussi incertaine n'est pas
envisageable
il nous faut donc apprendre à vivre avec
le co vie de 19 et apprendre à nous en
protéger voilà la première contrainte et
voilà le premier axe de notre stratégie
le deuxième constat est à la fois
médicale et politique
il tient au risque de voir repartir
l'épidémie
la décision de confiner notre pays a
permis de ralentir la circulation du
virus
elle a permis que jamais nos services de
réanimation ou de soins intensifs ne
soit saturé au point qu'il n'aurait pu
admettre de nouveaux patients elle a
permis à l'engagement des soignants à
l'imagination des équipes hospitalières
à l'organisation logistique des soins de
tenir en dépit d'une pression
considérable jamais vu mais de tenir et
je veux le dire une nouvelle fois ici
notre système hospitalier a tenu mais il
a tenu au prix d'une fatigue bien
compréhensible des femmes et des hommes
au prix d'une consommation de
médicaments de réanimation de
consommables jamais constaté non plus au
prix d'une déprogrammation des
opérations chirurgicales non nécessaires
à court terme mais qui finiront bien par
l'air le risque d'une seconde vague qui
viendrait frapper un tissu hospitalier
fragilisées qui imposerait un recond
finement lequel redresse les efforts et
les sacrifices consentis au cours de ces
huit semaines est un risque sérieux
un risque qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
ce risque impose de procéder avec
prudence
progressivement sûrement en reprenant
notre vie selon des modalités qui
permettent
semaine après semaine de vérifier que
nous maîtrisons le rythme de circulation
du virus
le deuxième axe de notre stratégie sera
donc la progressivité
le troisième élément à prendre en compte
et géographique
il tient là aussi en quelques mots la
circulation du virus n'est pas uniforme
dans le pays certaines parties ont été
durement touchés certains territoires
connaissent encore aujourd'hui après six
semaines de confinement un nombre
quotidien significatif de nouveaux cas
mais dans d'autres
le virus est quasiment absent cette
circulation hétérogène du virus créé de
fait des différences entre les
territoires
pour tous ceux qui comme moi croient au
bon sens il n'est pas inutile il est
même très nécessaire de prendre en
compte ces différences dans la façon
dont le déconfinement doit être organisé
à la fois pour ne pas appliquer le même
schéma dans des endroits où la situation
n'est objectivement pas la même mais
aussi pour laisser aux autorités locales
notamment au maire et au préfet la
possibilité d'adapter la stratégie
nationale en fonction des circonstances
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'avec le
président de la république nous avons
décidé de dire rapidement quel était
notre stratégie nationale afin qu'au
plus tôt ceux qui vont participer à sa
mise en oeuvre puissent prendre leurs
dispositions avec plusieurs membres du
gouvernement
avec le coordonnateur interministériel
jean castex
je rencontrerai dès demain les
associations d'élus locaux et les
préfets puis jeudi les partenaires
sociaux pour engager ce travail de
concertation et d'adaptation du plan aux
réalités de terrain
vivant avec le virus agir
progressivement adaptées localement
voilà les trois principes de notre
stratégie nationale à partir du 11 mai
sa mise en oeuvre va reposer sur le
triptyque protéger tester isolé protéger
d'abord
protéger cet évident et d'être éviter
d'être infecté par le virus ou
d'infecter les autres les médecins nous
disent que la contagiosité de la maladie
apparaît deux jours avant les premiers
symptômes et disparaît plusieurs jours
après il dit également qu une proportion
non négligeable de porteurs du virus ne
déclenche aucun symptôme et ne savent
pas au fond qu ils peuvent transmettre
le virus
dès lors il est impératif que chacun
puisse adopter les comportements qui
permettent d'éviter la contamination
à partir du moment où nous ne serons
plus en situation de confinement où les
occasions de contacts augmenteront à
nouveau il faudra les limiter mais elles
font plus importante qu'aujourd'hui le
respect des gestes barrières et des
mesures de distanciation social
distanciation physique préférant ce
terme prendra encore plus d'importance
ces gestes barrières tout le monde les
connaît désormais c'est notamment là dix
stations la distanciation physique et le
lavage régulier des mains
à cela il conviendra d'ajouter et je dis
bien d'ajouter le port du masque dans
certaines situations et je souhaite
revenir précisément sur ce sujet car
cette question des masques a suscité
l'incompréhension et la colère de
nombreux français
pourquoi il y en avait-il pas pour tout
le monde fallait-il emporté où les
trouver
lorsque la crise a commencé nous
disposions d'un stocks importants de
masques chirurgicaux important au sens
où ils permettaient de répondre à plus
de 20 semaines de consommation normale
des services hospitaliers la production
nationale était inférieure à la condamne
à la consommation normale mais complété
par des importations régulière
avec l'apparition de l'épidémie en chine
puis sont arrivés en italie
deux éléments sont apparus clairement
l'importation est momentanément devenu
impossible et la consommation a
considérablement augmenté dans des
proportions incroyablement supérieur à
la normale comme tous les pays européens
comme les états unis d'amérique la
france a dû gérer un risque de pénurie
de masques
trois décisions ont donc été prises
d'abord d'augmenter la production
nationale de masques chirurgicaux autant
que faire se peut ce n'est pas simple
mais nous sommes en train d'y parvenir
en doublant d'abord et en atteignant
bientôt cinq fois sa production initiale
ensuite réserver le stock existant aux
soignants hospitalier pour garantir la
fourniture de ces masques à ceux qui en
première ligne aurait à soigner les
malades
il est arrivé mesdames et messieurs les
députés que nous doutions de notre
capacité à garantir cet
approvisionnement dans la durée
réservez les masques aux soignants
c'était mécaniquement refusé de les
distribuer à d'autres c'est un choix
difficile
c'est un choix contesté c'est un fois
que j'ai estimé nécessaire enfin nous
avons lancé la production de masque en
tissu pour compléter l'offre et ne pas
dépendre des importations dont nous ne
savions pas si elles pourraient
reprendre
et si oui pour combien de temps les
scientifiques eux mêmes ont évolué au
début beaucoup nous disait que le port
du masque en population générale n'était
pas nécessaire que le risque du mauvais
usage étaient supérieurs aux avantages
espérés et nous l'avons répété et je les
dis ils nous disent aujourd'hui
parfois les mêmes qu'il est préférable
dont on ne brûle dans de nombreuses
circonstances de porter un masque plutôt
que de ne pas en porter et il me revient
donc de le dire et de faire en sorte que
cela soit possible
pendant la phase de pénurie nous avons
utilisé l'outil des réquisitions qui a
été fort utile depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant
depuis que nous sommes rassurés sur
notre capacité à servir les soignants au
sens large en masque nous incitons
l'ensemble des acteurs à se procurer des
masques et les données des douanes le
montre d'ailleurs assez clairement il
rentre bien plus de masques dans le pays
que le gouvernement n'en commet et
croyez moi ils en commande puisque nous
recevons près de 100 millions de masques
chirurgicaux par semaine désormais est
que nous recevrons près de 20 millions
de masques grand public lavable à
compter du mois de mai nous avons incité
les entreprises les collectivités à se
procurer également des masques
certaines n'ont pas attendu que vous les
incisions nous soutiendront
financièrement les collectivités locales
qui achètent à compter de ce jour des
masques grand public en prenant en
charge 50 % du coût des masques dans les
limites d'un prix de référence et nous
avons réouvert récemment vous l'avez
probablement remarqué les marchands de
tissus et les ateliers de couture et
diffuser des guides pratiques de
confection de masques afin que chacun se
mobilise pour en produire grâce à la
mobilisation de tous il y aura donc
assez de masques dans le pays pour faire
face aux besoins à partir du 11 mai mais
l'enjeu la responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics
notre responsabilité collective c'est
d'arriver dans les prochaines semaines a
organisé cet effort pour éviter que
certains entre guillemets en ait trop
quand d'autres n'en auraient pas
progressivement nous parviendrons à une
situation classique où les français
pourront sans risque de pénurie se
procurer des masques grand public dans
tous les commerces
en attendant il faut que l'état les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises
l'initiative privée soient
complémentaires et non concurrents le
président de la république l'a dit nous
nous appuierons sur les maires et les
préfets avec le concours de tous
j'invite toutes les entreprises quand
leurs moyens le permettent a veillé à
équiper leurs salariés c'est une
condition elles le savent elles le
disent de la reprise les régions et
l'état mettra en place un appui aux tpe
et aux travailleurs indépendants au delà
des initiatives déjà prises par un
certain nombre de branches ou
d'organiser
sur professionnels une plateforme de
e-commerce sera mise en place par la
poste à compter du 30 avril et
distribuera à ceux qui en ont besoin
chaque semaine plusieurs millions de
masques grand public
l'état et les collectivités locales
assureront la protection de leur
personnel en particulier ceux qui sont
en contact avec le public
les préfets et disposeront d'une
enveloppe locales pour soutenir avec les
collectivités territoriales les plus
petites collectivités
les personnels de l'éducation et les
élèves des collèges recevront également
des masques les pharmacies et la grande
distribution seront invités à vendre
dans des conditions dans des conditions
que nous définirons avec eux pour éviter
les phénomènes de pénurie des masques
jetables ou la 20 les particuliers sont
bien sûr invités je les dis à se
confectionner eux-mêmes des masques dans
les conditions recommandées par l'afnor
et par la nsr enfin nous réserveront une
enveloppe hebdomadaire de 5 millions de
masques lavables pour que les préfets
organise avec les maires et les
présidents de conseils départementaux la
distribution de masques à nos
concitoyens qui se trouvent dans le plus
grand état de précarité via les crs et
les acteurs associatifs protéger donc
tester ensuite
là encore les recommandations
scientifiques ont évolué et après tout
sans doute est ce normal
face à un virus inconnu cette crise
sanitaire renvoi décidément tout le
monde a un devoir d'humilité
la doctrine initial consistait dans ce
que nous appelions la phase 1 a testé au
maximum une d'ailleurs nous avons
beaucoup testé en phase 1
lorsqu'un cas est apparu aux contamines
montjoie et qu'il a fallu le
circonscrire
nous avons testé massivement tous ceux
qui s'était approché de près ou de loin
des malades identifiées mais la doctrine
voulait qu'une fois l'épidémie passer en
phase 3 on ne testent plus que les
malades hospitalisés pour suspicion de
coheed les soignants symptomatique et
les premiers cas dans les établissements
accueillant des publics fragiles c'est
ce que nous avons fait les temps ont
changé la doctrine de l'om associé à la
sortie du confinement
nous serons en capacité de massifier nos
tests nous nous sommes fixé l'objectif
de réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologique par semaine 11 mai pourquoi
cette envie parce que le conseil
scientifique nous dit que parce que le
conseil scientifique nous dit à ce stade
que les modèles épidémiologiques prévoit
entre 1000 et 3000 cas nouveaux chaque
jour à partir du 11 mai parce qu'à
chaque cas nouveau correspondra en
moyenne le test d'au moins 20 à 25
personnes l'ayant croisé dans les jours
précédents 3000 x 25 x 7
cela donne 525 milles test par semaine
sept cent mille nous donne la marge qui
nous permettra en plus des tests des
chaînes de contamination que je viens de
décrire de mettre en oeuvre des
campagnes de dépistage comme nous
l'avons déjà engagés pour les ehpad
notamment pour atteindre cette cible
nous avons fait sauter les verrous qui
empêchait la participation des
laboratoires de recherche et des
laboratoires vétérinaires à cet effort
collectif
la capacité à faire sauter ces verrous
sur le terrain pas seulement dans les
discours est un exercice qui incite là
aussi je peux vous le dire à une grande
humilité
nous avons engagé la mobilisation
conjointe des laboratoires publics et
privés qui peuvent aujourd'hui montée en
charge très rapidement en termes de
capacité cette mobilisation permettra de
garantir sur tout le territoire un accès
de proximité aux prélèvements nous
allons enfin faire passer à 100% la
prise en charge de cette de ces tests
pardon par l'assurance maladie
en un mot tout doit être fait pour
rendre la réalisation du test facile et
rapide dès lors qu'une personne n'aura
été testée positive nous engagerons un
travail d'identification et le test de
tous ceux symptomatique ou non qui
auront eu un contact rapproché avec elle
tous ces cas contacts seront testés et
seront invités à s'isoler
compte tenu des incertitudes sur la
durée d'incubation cette règle cette
règle est assez simple à formuler
mais elle exige pour être appliquée de
façon systématique par
tout en france des moyens considérables
nous ne pourrons réussir que grâce à la
mobilisation des professionnels de santé
libéraux notamment médecins généralistes
et infirmiers libéraux
ils constitueront d'une certaine manière
la première ligne dans cette recherche
des cas contacter pour tout ce qui
concerne la cellule familiale
je sais qu'ils peuvent se mobiliser pour
cette mission et nous les accompagnerons
pour cela on appuie les équipes de
l'assurance-maladie assureront la
démultiplication de cette démarche
d'identification des cas contacts au
delà de la cellule familiale dans chaque
département nous constituerons des
brigades chargées de remonter la liste
des cas contacts de les appeler de les
inviter à se faire tester en leur
indiquant à quel endroit ils doivent se
rendre
puis à vérifier que ces tests ont bien
eu lieu et que leurs résultats donnent
lieu à l'application correcte de la
doctrine nationale protéger d'abord
tester ensuite est isolé enfin
l'objectif final de cette politique
ambitieuse de test
ces deux permettre d'isoler au plus vite
les porteurs du virus afin de casser les
chaînes de transmission l'isolément
mesdames et messieurs les députés n'est
pas une punition isolement n'est pas une
sanction d'isolement c'est une mesure de
précaution collective c'est une mise à
l'abri isolement doit donc être
expliquée consentis et accompagner notre
politique repose à cet égard sur la
responsabilité individuelle et la
conscience que chacun doit avoir de ses
devoirs à l'égard des autres nous
prévoirons des dispositifs de contrôle
s'il devait être nécessaire mais notre
objectif est de nous reposer largement
sur le civisme de chacun et on observe
d'ailleurs les médecins le disent ce
qu'ils ont eu à gérer des épidémies le
dise que la conscience individuelle le
respect civique des règles lorsque l'on
est déclaré positif ou malades et
souvent quasiment absolu
il reviendra au préfet et aux
collectivités territoriales de définir
ensemble avec les acteurs associatifs
les professionnels de santé les acteurs
de la prise en charge à domicile le plan
d'accompagnement des personnes placées
dans cette forme d'isolement
nous laisserons le choix à la personne
testée positive de s'isoler chez elle ce
qui entraînera le confinement de tous le
foyers pendant 14 jours pour des raisons
évidentes ou bien de s'isoler dans un
lieu mis à sa disposition notamment dans
des hôtels réquisitionné un mot encore
sur ce sujet mais un mot important
pourrons-nous ou devrons-nous afin
d'être plus efficaces nous appuyer sur
les ressources extraordinaires des
outils numériques
un consortium européen a lancé un
travail devant permettre la création de
l'application stop que vides dont
l'utilité ne peut s'envisager que de
façon complémentaire à ce que je viens
de décrire complémentaires parce que les
enquêtes sanitaires que j'ai décrite
qu'elle soit physique ou téléphonique
sont vitales mais présente une faiblesse
elle se heurte parfois dans les centres
urbains à l'impossibilité de
reconstituer les scènes de transmission
dans les lieux les plus denses et
notamment dans les transports en commun
difficile de prévenir
celui qui a partagé votre rame de métro
à 7h46 sur la ligne 12
vous ne le connaissez pas il ne vous
connais pas et la ratp ne connaît ni
l'un ni l'autre
c'est l'objet du projet stop que vides
qui permettrait aux personnes qui ont
croisé une personne testée positive
d'intégrer un parcours sanitaires sans
bien entendu avoir aucune information
sur l'identité de la personne croisée un
grand nombre de responsables politiques
sur tous les bancs le président de
l'assemblée nationale lui même ont fait
part de leurs interrogations sur 7
peu d'instruments sur les questions que
son utilisation ne manquerait pas de
poser en termes de libertés publiques et
de libertés individuelles
[Musique]